Ich hoffe jetzt tut's
Lull
Mal gucken ob das Telekom Lack
sich jetzt wieder beruhigt hat
What the fuck
Ich seh jetzt bei mir nichts
Läufts bei euch?
Ich hab in meinem Vorschaufenster
grad ne ganz tolle Fehlermeldung
Läufts bei euch?
In meinem Vorschaufenster hab ich grad
The Twitch Machine
got unplugged, try again in a moment
Error 5000
Es sollte kein Black Screen sein
Jetzt gehts
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Alter was geht mit dem Vogel ab
Da fuck
Error 5000
Ich verstehs nicht
Was auch immer
Ich find die Settings von Twitch
immer so geil ne, ich ändere ja an meinem
OBS nichts
Gar nix, nie, ändere euch an meinem
OBS was, ja und jedes mal ist es irgendwie
anders
Und ich hab mir gedacht
Ich kann jetzt einfach mal Streben anmachen
Weil ich spiel eh den ganzen Tag schon Kingmaker
Und ich hab mir gedacht, ja gut, warum soll ich nicht einfach
einfach im Streben spielen
Ich bin aber auch schon
ein bisschen weiter, weil vor allem der Anfang
ist auch ein bisschen langweilig
Und für alle die
so klassische RPGs mögen
ist das Game echt geil, kann man wirklich empfehlen
Zoomt
Mein Mammut geht mir auf den Sack
Der macht die ganze Zeit nervige
Geräusche
Mammut, geh mal weg
Ich muss jetzt nämlich mal ganz
kurz skillen
Das wird auch nicht leiser, wenn man weiter weggeht
Ich geh jetzt
von meinem Mammut weg, wenn Mammut
nix zu tun hat
Oh, was ist das?
Give loot
Äh wie ist die Lautstärke von mir
und zum Game, passt auch, wie gesagt ich hab nix
verstellt, aber man weiß ja nie
so genau
Äh Säureaura
Klingt gut, das wäre natürlich
noch besser, wenn ich es dem Charakter geben könnte
der irgendwie vorne steht oder so
Aber hab ich nicht
Dann kriegt es mein Clary jetzt
Das kriegt mein Clary
Der hat nämlich nix an
Das ist Naked sozusagen
Wo ist es denn?
Sortieren, zack
Easy
So, jetzt wollen wir mal ganz kurz skillen
Oh ne, Mammut, bleib weg
Passt, nice, sehr schön
Äh ich werd ganz kurz skillen, dann sag ich was
zu meiner Party hier mal am Start
Ähm
Aber mal ganz
schnell eine Runde specken
Weil auf Level 8 tut's ihnen ja allzu viel
Ich hab extra gewartet
bis ich Level abhabe, quasi jetzt mal
zu einer neuen Quest gehe und hab ich gedacht, komm jetzt machst du es
einfach mal streben an
So, was brauchen wir im Brau? Auf jeden Fall mehr Charisma
Für mehr Zauber-Bash, ganz wichtig
Ähm
Da, da, da
Dass wir ordentlich in Dialogen ordentlich
was reißen können, weiter, zack fertig
Zauber Spezialisierung
Bester Skill überhaupt
Magic Missile, bäm, fertig
Achso, jetzt muss ich auch noch was auswählen
Was, oh das ist mein erster
Level 4 Zauber, was taugt denn da
was, zeig mal her
Ähm, also für AE hab ich
mein Feuerball schon am Start
da brauch ich sonst nix
Ich glaub das ist ziemlich nice, da kann man sich
teleportieren
Ja, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich
hab vom Pathfinder
Regelwerk absolut keine
Ahnung, ich hab ein bisschen
Ahnung von Dungeons & Dragons
Ich hab eine ganze Kampagne
bisher gespielt in 5e
und halt die ganzen ollen Games gespielt, die auf
3-5 basieren und soweit ich weiß
ist Pathfinder
äh, Dungeons & Dragons
3.5 Fork quasi
Die haben irgendwie das 3.5
Regelwerk genommen und ein bisschen
was da dran herum gedockt dort
Dementsprechend kennt man sich da eigentlich
ganz gut aus
Teleports, es ist halt die Frage ob das gut ist
ne, weil man Gegner irgendwie jetzt sagen wir mal
den Berg runter teleportieren kann, ist schon nicht
schlecht, aber nachdem man seine Gruppe
auch teleportieren kann
Scheint das nicht
übel zu sein, das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal
Na ja, Stufe 10 Zauber haben wir noch
keine, ich weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt Stufe 10 Zauber gibt
Next
Fertig, save
Wir spielen übrigens nicht auf schwer
sondern ich spiel hier auf
Challenge
einfach weil die
Monster dann ein bisschen mehr aushalten
und der Schwierigkeitsgrad
eher dem ist wie es irgendwie sein soll
und wenn ich mir überlege
wie bei diesem Game rumgeheult
wurde auf Steam auch, ne
das ist schon richtig krass gewesen
hab ich eigentlich Qualitätsoptionen mittlerweile
Na wie krass auch bei diesem Game rumgeheult wurde
auf Steam, wie schwer das ist
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, weil man ein bisschen
aufpasst was man
speckt und ein bisschen, dass ein bisschen
taktischer spielt, das ist überhaupt
gar kein Ding
ich weiß ja nicht was die Leute alle haben
So, Valerie kriegt ein Dex mehr
dann hat sie 16 Dex und eine Rüstungsklasse
mehr und ja ansonsten
braucht die nicht wirklich großartig was
brauchen wir alles nicht, vielleicht kann sie
was kochen später wenn man
Welt wissen
auch wenn das
wenn es die Feministen sehen, dann gehts wieder ab
ja wenn man kochen will
für die Gruppe braucht man hier
Wissen auf Welt
warum auch immer
weil
so und dann brauchen wir jetzt auch irgendwas für
mehr Rüstung
mehr Rüstung ist immer gut
Schildfokus
Schildfokus ist nice
da kriegen wir bestimmt
noch mehr Rüstungsklasse
das heißt wir haben jetzt 35
Rüstungsklasse, das ist übertrieben krass
schon hyped auf Blackout, unglaublich
tatsächlich muss ich sagen
von den ganzen Battle Royale Games
ich fand das jetzt gar nicht so schlecht
ich fand es gar nicht so übel
was kommt denn das eigentlich raus
das ist nicht mehr so lang oder
nächste Woche oder so 12.
12. kommt das raus
immer Skillzorn
Barb
ähm
ja die kriegt natürlich Stärke was sonst
wobei die sicherlich auch einmal
Dex gebrauchen können, aber Stärke
Damage muss sein
zack, zack und
keine Ahnung
ich vollkommen egal was wir hier speckten
mehr
zweites Level davon, jawoll
so unser Bardel
braucht auch ein neues Level
die dürfte wir auf dem Level nicht allzu viel kriegen
Charisma
zack, zack, zack
so
was nehmen wir für Level 3 Zauber
für unseren Bardel
am 12. kommt glaube ich
Black Ops raus
ich glaube am 12. kommt Black Ops raus
ich bin ja mal gespannt ob das
wirklich
was nehmen wir denn hier
erstmal kurz überlegen
Lindsey ist hier eher so mein
CC und
vor allem Buff Charakter
Magiebann haben wir schon
Heal brauchen wir nicht, da haben wir unseren
Clary, der Haltknopf. Haste habe ich auf
meinem Held, das brauchen wir auch nicht
Gift habe ich auch auf dem Clary
ok
das trifft aber auch eigene
das ist blöd
das ist auch ein Kack, das brauchen wir nicht
keine Ahnung
ich tendiere ja da, aber noch mehr
Haste Ladung brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht
ich habe auf meinem
Hexenmeister
Haste
das reicht, habe ich 6 Ladung Haste
das reicht zwischen jeder Rasse, das brauche ich nicht
haben wir hier noch irgendwelche
AE Sachen, die
nur Feinde treffen
das habe ich auch auf meinem Clary
das brauche ich alles nicht
alle Feinde verlangsamen, das habe ich auch schon
auf meinem Held, eigentlich brauche ich die ganzen Zauber nicht
verwirren
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
das habe ich auf meinem Clary schon
wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
das hier, dass wir uns auch
durch schweres Gelände schnell
bewegen können, die ganze Gruppe
ich glaube zwar nicht, dass wir das oft brauchen, aber
wenn wir das brauchen, ist es bestimmt gar nicht so übel
oh nice
neues
Barred Song
Clary's Becken
Hast du Overwatch World Cup geguckt?
ein bisschen habe ich geguckt
ich habe geguckt wie Team Germany
auf den Sack gekriegt hat
wie die
Schweiz was glaube ich auf den Sack gekriegt hat
das UK und Frankreich
ziemlich geohnt haben
oh was gibt es denn hier auf Level 8
das ist Special Fähigkeit von der Klasse
Heilige Lanze auf Stufe 8
kannst du bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
was bringt es?
Stufe 8 einmal täglich hier
was macht es?
ok, Damage Buff für irgendeine Nahkampfwaffe
das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
kann man sich einfach vor dem Fight buffen
bei dem kann ich eigentlich nur
Weisheitsbecken
das bringt das nächste
nächsten 4 Level oder sowas
zack zack
tja
wirklich
keine Ahnung
brauche ich eigentlich alles nicht
so
jetzt noch mal einen Ranger
und dann geht es los
Waldläufer Level 8, was gibt es da?
Bevorzug des Gelände wählen
was hat er denn als erstes?
Bevorzug des Gelände, Wald
was kann man mal gucken
was man da alles auswählen kann
Geschick, was kriegt der?
Constincts Weisheit
kriegt auch mehr Decks
für mehr Damage, wobei das als nächstes
Level irgendwie was bringt
brauche ich das alles nicht
was ich hier specken kann
doch, keine Ahnung
ja
zack
so
Ebene erstellt Hochland
Stadt Untergrund
Dungeon
auf gehts
mal einen krassen Mammut Pet
das immer alle hauen
Gegen Frankreich hätte Team Germany fast gewonnen
okay
das habe ich, das könnte sogar sein
als ich das geguckt habe
ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher
es könnte sein, als ich geguckt habe
das war dann 3-2 oder so
übelst knapp
ich weiß gar nicht, wann das überhaupt losgeht
ist das wieder auf der Gamescom?
ne, die Gamescom war ja schon
ne, auf der, eigentlich nicht auf der Gamescom
auf der Blizzcon
läuft
auf der Gamescom
ja, fast
okay, guck mal mal
also, immer so, für alle die jetzt einschalten
wie gesagt, ich bin ja Level 8
und ich habe schon eine Weile gespielt, ich bin in Act 2
und wir sind hier gerade dabei
wir machen hier das Quest
Verschwundenes Kind
wir suchen irgendein Kind
ein Kind, was abgehauen ist, aus der Hauptstadt
weil, ich meine, wir sind zwar
kann ich euch die Map von hier zeigen?
ne
wir sind zwar Baron
und könnten uns eigentlich um Regierungsaufgaben kümmern
aber nein
wir ziehen ja noch selbst los
und erledigen sinnlose
Hohle 5 Eierquests
warum?
weil das auch sein muss
ja, und dann machen wir allerdings hier
die, die Quest, wo wir hier gucken, was auf der Insel los ist
oh, oh, the fuck
wo ist der gar nicht erst ein Gegner am Start
weil, guckst du hier in dein Quest schon, Nadel auf einmal
ja
ok, alleine sind die Dinger nicht so das Problem
die machen übelst
Elektrizitätsdamage
alleine sind die kein Problem
das war richtig, MonkaS
aber wenn es mehr sind
das machen die übelst Damage
zumal die den Hang dazu haben
alles auf meinen Held zu schießen
wenn der Held, ja, er hier
wenn der Held down ist
ist alles down
und ich warne euch schon mal vor
nachdem wir auf schwierig spielen
also nicht auf schwer, sondern auf
also nicht auf normal, sondern auf challenge
auf fordernd heißt das glaube ich
auf deutsch, der Schwierigkeitsmodus
nachdem wir auf relativ schwierig spielen
kann es sein, dass wir öfters mal neu laden müssen
aber das Spiel ist wirklich easy
ne, der ist nicht tot
doch, der ist tot
das Spiel ist nicht schwierig
also, ne, ihr müsst ja mal was steam gucken
ich zeige euch das mal kurz
hallo, was habe ich jetzt hier aufgemacht
steam
ich muss euch das mal zeigen, die Leute
das ist total beknackt
die haben echt
den übelsten Dachschaden
oh ja, mittlerweile
hat es mostly positive
also bei release hat das Spiel mixed Kritiken
weil die Leute alle
krass rumgeheult haben, wie schwer das ist
die haben alle so rumgeheult
wie schwer das Game ist
und ich dachte mir schon so, boah ey
endlich mal quasi was mit einem
gut umgesetzten
pen and paper regelwerk
mal gucken, wie das ist
muss man sich bestimmt voll einlesen, dass das klappt
ne, game angemacht
bisschen Theorie crafted, wie könnte man sein
hellskillen, zack, bumm, alles weggebashed
ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich für schmerzen habe
es gab am Anfang so eine Quest
da musste man, also ihr kennt ja so
wenn man in RPGs anfängt
die erste Quest ist immer Ratten killen, Spinnen killen
oder sonst was in der Richtung
und natürlich gab es hier
in Kingmaker gab es natürlich auch so eine Quest
für Töte irgendwie
in die Spinnenhöhle und bringen alle Spinnen um
und das Game hat hier vorher extra
also ne
es hat hier gesagt, es steht nämlich in dieser
Stadt, wo man losgeht, so ein Alchemist rum
der hat gesagt hier, nehmen Alchemist Feuer mit
weil Spinnen sind anfällig
gegen Feuer, also habe ich mir gedacht
ok, machst einfach ein paar Alchemistbomben
skills fast, skills ein bisschen
Feuer und die Spinnen wurden weg
gebashed ohne Ende
und das ist das, diese Stelle
da habe ich irgendwie drei Minuten für gebraucht
war mega easy, wo ganz Steam rumgeheult
hat, so nach dem, oh mein Gott, das Game ist so
schwer, ich weiß
nicht, also manchmal habe ich das Gefühl
manchmal denke ich irgendwie so
die Leute haben
verlernt
Games zu spielen
weil, weil quasi
jedes Game heute aus Tutorials
besteht, die sich über das ganze Game hinziehen
Onscreen Hinweise, du bist ja auch
komplett frei, wenn wir hier durch sind, zeige ich euch
die Worldmap, du bist relativ frei, wo du
hingehst und das sind die, ich glaube
das sind die Leute nicht mehr gewöhnt
oder auch, und was, was
generell Spieler von heute nicht mögen
habe ich den Eindruck ist, wenn man
irgendwas nicht schaffen kann
später
wiederzukommen, das ist hier halt so, hier trifft
man öfters mal in irgendeiner Höhle
trifft man halt
Monster, die halt
da hausen und die
halt einfach mal acht Level über dir
sind oder sowas
und die kannst du halt einfach nicht bashen
was willst du machen, da gehst du einfach raus
und kommst einfach ein paar Level später
wieder und bashst weg, das ist
kein Ding
sagen wir mal, bin ich überladen oder so?
ich glaube ich bin tatsächlich überladen
was ich nicht vergessen darf, ha
ich habe mein Clary gespeckt, da kann ja noch
da kann er
neue Sachen auswählen
und
ne, ich kann nichts mehr auswählen
wir rasten mal kurz
falls man die rasten darf
ich glaube
darf man die rasten
und ich muss sagen, ich finde auch, dass
dieses Camping System
wie übelst nice, wie sie das gemacht haben
das ist halt, man merkt halt, dass
sie sich da schon einigen Pan and Paper
Regelwerk orientiert haben, wo normalerweise
Leute um den Tisch zusammensitzen
weil das ist halt, auf den ersten Blick sieht es halt
überkompliziert aus, wie man
quasi rasten kann
guckt euch das mal an
was the fuck
sprich, das Rastsystem ist komplizierter
als das Kampfsystem in manchen
Games heutzutage
aber im Prinzip ist es eigentlich relativ einfach
man braucht irgendeiner
der sich gut auskennt hier in Wissen
Welt, der kann kochen, dann brauchst du irgendeiner
der gut stelzen kann, der kann das Lager
tarn, dann brauchst du irgendeiner, der gut in Natur ist
der kann Zeug jagen, dein
Clary kann am Feuer sitzen und alle heil und der Rest
schiebt Wache, fertig
mehr musst du eigentlich nicht beachten
wenn du das nämlich verkackst
und vielleicht sehen wir das jetzt ja auch
das kann schon sein, wenn ich jetzt hier
campen werde ich nämlich nachts über
werde ich nämlich nachts überfallen
von
was auch immer das hier jetzt ist
Bashen einfach
au
geh weg, oh fuck
die stehen voller mal am Held dran
oh, das war keine gute Idee
die haben ja
die haben übrigens mein Held gebasht
das ist aber fies, ja
haben wir negative stufe habe ich noch fluch fluchbrechen ausgewählt mit meinem clary
sonst muss ich jetzt gleich noch mal rasten
ähm
fluch
äh muss denn fluch
nein das hab ich natürlich nicht ausgerüstet
na
geil
das heißt ich muss jetzt mein clary gleich mal ausrüsten mit
fluch
fluchbrechen
ja
weg hier
fluchbrechen
das ist übrigens verbugt
also man kann normalerweise die domain zauber in jeden slot packen aber auf den höhere level gehts nicht mehr
das ist irgendwie verbugt
fluchbrechen
fluchbrechen und jetzt rasten
safe
ja und man sieht jetzt das war jetzt quasi ein
ich wurde quasi nachts überfallen auf dem höheren schwierigkeitsgrad
und trotzdem ist nichts passiert
alter
ist ja gut
da fuck
der treibbau
ok dann brauchen wir erstmal badensong an
ähm
clary healed einmal
ich mach eine runde haste auf meine leute
der ballert auf den baum
zack
next
easy
buff sind alles in dem game so geil
so darf ich jetzt vielleicht moment moment nicht rasten nicht rasten
hat der clary schon sein zeugs gerekt
stufe 2
fluchbrechen
ne hat er noch nicht
das ist natürlich blöd
also es ist so
das ist wie wie in
dungeons
dungeons und dragons 3 5
ich weiß nicht
ganz aus dem kopf gar nicht wie es in 5e ist
du musst halt als wizard und als clary musst du dir halt in dein buch schreiben was für zauber du gerade verwenden willst
und dann musst du einmal rasten
sag mal
darf ich rasten heute noch mal irgendwann
the fuck
oder darf ich hier nicht rasten
ich gehe gleich wieder aus dem gebiet raus raste einmal und gehe wieder ins gebiet rein wenn du so weiter gehst
so mein mammoth rennt jetzt mal an den baum darunter
du ballerst auf den baum hier unten drauf
bardo macht song an
clary macht segen an
und du ess
und dann werden sie geschreckt die bäume
hey max holst du dir das neue anno
äh
ich überlege gerade was das neue anno ist
was war denn das neue anno
eigentlich mag ich nämlich die serie
anno 1800 ok
das habe ich schon voll verdrängt irgendwie dass das in nächster zeit kommt
also wenn es nicht so verkacken wie bei simcity ich weiß es hat jetzt nichts zu tun
aber simcity fand ich auch immer ganz gut
und das letzte simcity war halt
kompletter reinfall ne
sag mal
ich darf nicht rasten
wollte mich vera- was das
alter monkaS
und wieder voll in meinem held drinne
mein held ist down
na geil
so wisst ihr was ich lade jetzt und gehe von der insel runter raste einmal und dann gehe ich wieder auf die insel
so
scheiß drauf
ich raste die
ich gehe jetzt von der insel runter und raste
kein bock jetzt auf den scheiß hier
hallo serious max
warum soll ich auf der insel rasten wo mich nichts rasten lässt wenn ich einfach von der insel runter gehen kann und rasten
eigentlich wollte ich nur rasten dass ich meine clary spells kriege und es geht immer weiter bergab
ah hier gibt es neue events
also jetzt kann ich euch mal die weltkarte zeigen an der stelle
das ist übelst groß
hier ist meine hauptstadt irgendwo
äh da ist meine hauptstadt
die zweite stadt die ich da oben hinge- hingebaut hab
das geht das game mal zu den mini
zu den mini wirtschaftszweig
also so ganz kleine so ein bisschen
ähm wo man sich halt um seinen
sein
nicht königreich sein wie nennt man das auf deutsch
seine baronie kümmern muss
ja da muss man irgendwie ähm
bürgermeister
äh ne nicht bürgermeister irgendwie
ja leute ernennen
die für spezielle sachen zuständig sind
wie militär und
und kram also der zweig ist nicht
allzu ausgeprägt ja
ja und was ich cool finde
dass auch in alten gebieten wo man schon war öfters
mal was neues kommt ja zum beispiel hier hütte
der sumpfhex ist jetzt irgendwie neues erhalten das kann ich hin
und stell es in sonn ich zeig euch mal die
map
soweit ich
hier überblicken kann kann man hier überall hin
bis zum rand das ist
übelst groß ne im meisten gebieten bin ich noch
gar nicht gewesen ich bin eigentlich hauptsächlich hier
diese mittleren gebiete unterwegs gibt sau viele
punkte wo man gucken kann und hinter
jedem dieser punkte steckt im endeffekt so ne map
wie ich jetzt eben gerade gewesen bin
also ist auch ordentlich umfangreich
so jetzt campen wir mal
in der
hoffnung dass wir nicht wieder überfallen werden
ha
sogar guck mal
sogar das kochen hat funktioniert
eats as fuck
äh servus max kannst du
kurz was zu dem game sagen
ich finde das ist das game ist wirklich top
ich finde das ist das beste
das beste so so
classic rpg der letzten
in letzter zeit ja
und ich hab fast alles gespielt ich hab
ich hab pillars gespielt ich hab pillars 2
was gab's da noch
original zil 1 und 2 pillars of eternity
1 und 2
ähm
ich hab fast alles gespielt was es so
an klassischen
rpg's
gegeben hat in letzter
zeit
und
ich muss sagen das gefällt mir
bisher noch mit am besten
was hat es nicht geklappt
ach ne da braucht man genesung für
da braucht man gar nicht fluchbrechen für
nein das ist ja rolldich da muss ich dann eh wieder
in die hauptstadt ey das ist ja scheiße
das war mal ganz schön kacke
besser als ballos
besser als ballos naja
das kann man so nicht sagen ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich von ballos gate 1
war ich kein großer fan
wow oh ne hab ich nicht
gespeichert ich kacke noob
oh ne
manchmal bin ich echt
manchmal bin ich echt dumm
doch ich hab gespeichert
es hat auto
gesaved
ok jetzt ist es natürlich ein bisschen doof jetzt hat
mein held level abzüge
da muss ich erst in die hauptstadt um das ganze heilen zu können
da sieht man halt auch dass es
bisschen bisschen schwieriger ist
besser
naja also ballos gate kann ich
dazu sagen was wollte ich jetzt machen ich wollte erstmal mal
in clary nochmal wieder ordentliche spells geben
hat er jetzt eigentlich
genesung mittlerweile
clary genesung
hat er genesung
ja nice ich kanns heilen
das ist doch gut
ich kanns heilen nice
deswegen braucht man immer einen clary
clary beste
so wir wollen ein gebet haben
zack gebet
ich sag gleich was was ich zu ballos gate denke
gebet brauchen wir
und
bisschen damage kann im endeffekt auch nicht
schaden den der clary noch machen kann
ähm
so jetzt müssen wir noch einmal rasten
und dann müsste es eigentlich gut passen
also
besser als ballos gate also
ballos gate vom ersten teil bin ich
persönlich überhaupt kein fan
ballos gate also von ballos gate 1
wurde gemerkt das war mir
durch die bank weg zu langsam
und noch zu wenig ausgereift das ganze
zumal es in ballos gate 1
ganz viele klassen gibt also in der ursprünglichen variante
die halt zacken
so wizard die ersten paar level ist
kacke
ballos gate 2 war übelst gut
für die damalige zeit
ich finde es wird ein bisschen zu sehr
mit ähm
ja nostalgiebrille drauf
geguckt ballos gate hatte auch schon ein paar nervige
sachen so beschränktes inventar
und sonst was was ballos gate 2
und auch die erweiterung auf jeden
fall hatte
was weit über dem
liegt was die meisten spiele heutzutage
haben ist
ähm wie es geschrieben
ist
mal gucken ob ich jetzt mal eine debuff los werde
ich speichere mal vorher
auf clary
mach hinne
ja ok passt
ich hab doch genesel
zwei mal ausgewählt oder
was zum teufel
ich kann das nur einmal ausführen
warum
ach weil mir
oh gott ey
ich kanns nur einmal ausführen weil ich nicht die richtigen
komponenten zum zaubern dabei habe
auch gar nicht krieg anfälle ey
egal wir
oh shit
fail
na gut da müssen wir jetzt durch
wir müssen
eh danach in die hauptstadt
da kaufe ich mir ne scroll und gut ist
oh
gift neutralisieren haben wir schon
und noch nen heal
so speichern so und jetzt rasten wir noch einmal
und dann gehts los ey alter was
was ein akte
besser als divinity 2 anders
äh divinity 2 fand ich auch nice
vor allem nachdem es ich weiß gar nicht ob es es schon
gibt
hast du nicht das
komponentenlos zaubern talent
nein hab ich nicht bis jetzt hab ich noch
keinen einzigen zauber gesehen der überhaupt ne
komponente braucht
das ist der erste zauber wo ich auch gesehen hab
dass man dafür was braucht
ein komponente und
ich hab mir auch ehrlich gesagt
keine gedanken zugemacht dass das
notwendig ist weil in
in 5e
können claris ja
ohne komponenten
zaubern wenn sie eben ihr
ihr
holy symbol also sprich ihr
von ihrem jeweiligen gott
so nen anhänger oder so was dabei
haben
was anscheinend
so nicht ist hier
was aber nicht schlimm ist ich mein ich werde es
überleben
level abzug
auf
dem
dem hexenmeister ist jetzt zwar nicht schön
aber wir kriegen es wir kriegen das schon hin
es ist überhaupt ein level abzug
oder was gibt es ja level abzug
wir müssen in die hauptstadt
danach
hab jetzt auf youtube gesehen dass
einige battlefield veteranen battle für 5
nicht mal so schlecht finden naja
ich muss ich muss sagen
wenn sie da ein paar sachen
ändern also das basch potenzial
bei battlefield 5 ist auf jeden fall da
das das was
mich am meisten an battlefield 5 genervt hat ist
halt dass sie an jede
irgendwelche animationen gepappt haben
sowie hochklettern auf
den wagon also sprich auf den
abzug was dann immer nicht funktioniert
wo du 5 mal dahinter springen musst und so was
also diese animations
gedulds ging mir in battlefield
5 eigentlich am meisten auf den keks
ja auch noch was zum thema besser als
divinity 2 kann ich kann man kann man so
nicht sagen es ist halt
deutlich mehr
merkt man dass es einen
so
so ein klassischen
panel paper sachen orientiert ist wie das
mit dem rast system und halt dass es nicht
rundenbasiert ist sondern
wie bald
aus geld
echtzeit mit pause
ja
also wir wissen jetzt das den gegner da können wir uns
noch eine sache zu bald aus geld
also wie gesagt ich bin der
meinung wie es geschrieben ist bald aus geld 2
ist das deutlich besser als die
meisten anderen games heutzutage was dialogue
angeht und halt auch wie was die
die charaktere für hintergründe haben und so was
auch besser als
kingmaker da ist bald aus geld 2 wirklich
richtig gut
vor allem damals haben sie es halt auf den punkt gebracht
da hat ein charakter nicht eine halbe stunde gelabert
und eine halbe stunde text vor sich gegeben
sondern 5 dialogfelder und du wusstest Bescheid
so also wir wissen jetzt das den
gegner wie gehen wir das ganze jetzt am
besten an wir buffen uns erstmal
mit
nein tristan
das wollen wir nicht
wir wollen
schutz vor elektrizität das wollen wir
auf jeden fall haben dann
wollen wir haben haste
dass wir schneller bashen können
und dann wollen wir
baden sorgen haben und dann
wird geschreckt
auf gehts
jetzt kriegen sie aufs marble
so mein
mammut geht mal hier hoch
dass der beschäftigt ist mammut
kommst du da nicht durch
zack da können sie gar nichts mehr
buffen ist das halbe
guck mal easy easy
der lebt noch
zack wenn man gebufft ist
ist das ganze nur halb so schwer
und ich glaube das ist auch
das warum viele so rumgemerkt haben dass das
game so schwer ist
weil man kommt halt nicht so wirklich
weiter mit oder ist ein gegner man klickt
drauf bam alles kaputt das geht mit
irgendwelchen level 1 wölfen oder so geht
das
da ist wieder so ein fies
mit irgendwelchen level 1 wölfen
oder so geht das ja aber mit
schwereren gegnern ist das halt nicht mehr so drinnen
da ist er down
aber schon gelooted
was gibt es denn hier
ist ein naturathletik
da können wir hier hoch wir laufen
bevor wir den weg ausprobieren
laufen wir einmal drum herum und gucken
uns das ganze hier so an wie es so weiter geht
man kann nämlich
deswegen ist es auch ein bisschen wichtig
dass man
ausgewogen
seine fertigkeiten
skillt
man sieht mein mammut
weiß nicht sonderlich viel
mein mammut ist ziemlich dumm
mein mammut ist übelst dumm
intelligenz 2
aber eigentlich was ich zeigen wollte
ist dass es hier halt sinnvoll ist
wenn man das zeug skillt weil
zum beispiel hier kann man jetzt halt
man hält das hier bloß 10 auf
wissen natur das heißt der könnte jetzt
hier einen check machen und das ist halt deutlich näher
an irgendeiner pen and paper vorlage dran
sein natur check machen ob man hier nicht drüber kommt
oder alternativ könnte
hier irgendwie amiri oder hier meinen
ranger gucken
ob sie es mit irgendeinem atletik check schaffen
aber wir laufen erstmal drum herum und gucken
warum kommen keine youtube videos
von mir
weil mir also hauptsächlich
liegt daran weil mir die games fehlen
hauptsächlich weil mir die games fehlen
die ich geil finde
und die auf youtube passen
ey wir machen jetzt mal trick 17
wir werden jetzt mal richtig debaten
die gegner
falls hier ein gegner ist
mal gucken
was ist das
das war keine so gute idee mit meinem held vorzulaufen
drauf
einer nach der
weg, weg Fokus
Leute, lasst doch mal den Wolf durch
au, au, au, au, au, au, au
Clary, einmal healen bitte
Clary, heilen
ok, nice
Alter
Die haben ja aber echt ganz schön auf den Sack
fehlt mir ein Spell hier
ja, mir fehlt ein Spell
ich kann sagen, irgendwie ist es so leer in der Leiste
einmal noch healen
ich hab ja nicht so viele Lebenspunkte
das lässt sich ja relativ einfach heilen
Kennste das kein FTL?
ja, ja klar
das aber auch schon, das ist ja von 2012 oder so
das ist das mit dem Raumschiff
wo man die unterschiedlichen
ähm
tja, so Abteilung vom Raumschiff
managen muss und Energie
für Türme und so
ja, das kenn ich klar
hab ich aber nie lang gespielt
ach, deswegen hab ich so ins Maul auf die Fresse gekriegt
gerade, die anderen haben alle noch
ihren
Elektroresi-Buff
und ich hab nichts plus
Levelabzug
das ist natürlich so geil
warum sind die so langsam
die sind doch gar nicht überladen oder so
as it should be
oh
ach gut, das ist nur einer, der kann nichts
schießen wir mal mit drauf, dass der auch down geht
treffen alle nichts
ach, nix
Mammut
Mammut macht das jetzt
aua
ey, die Dinger hauen halt echt rein, ne
einmal heal
nicht
nicht Rage anmachen
nix im Fight Rage anmachen
heal
und einmal AE heal
Schatztruhe, zack
oh nice
1 plus 3 Kriegshammer
der das ausrüsten kann
hier sind 100 pro noch mehr
boh
direkt in mir drin
da kommen noch mehr
wir machen mal Barzong an
Pless vom Clary
und drauf Newton
guck das
ok, ich bin down
Pfadfinder
ja fast
ja das kann einem auf dem höheren
Schwierigkeitsgrad halt mal ganz
gerne passieren, dass man
3 unglückliche Treffer auf den
Held kriegt, man ist down
aber nachdem wir jetzt ja wissen, dass
da Gegner sind
machen wir jetzt
noch mal
buffen wir uns
noch mal Barzong an
buffen wir uns weiter
und dann
versuchen wir mal
die Gegner zu blenden
und danach casten wir noch Haste
und bashen sie weg
versuchen wir den Gegner mal zu blenden, hier irgendwo war der, oder?
oder auch nicht
ne, kein Gegner da
Pech gehabt
da ist er doch
so, eine Runde, Max, hau mal ab
Max, geh weg
geh weg, lass mich nicht
bashen, alter
so
Clary AE Heal
auu, alter
lass mich den ruhen ey
der Clary
du scheiß, ok ich muss mit meinem
Held weg, der kriegt übelst auf die Fresse an
ich will, also
ich könnte einfach wieder Resi-Buff
Elektro Resi-Buff machen, allerdings
geht sie hier noch weiter
und nachdem man so schlecht campen kann
und man muss campen
dafür, dass man seine spells wiederkriegt
will ich mir den erstmal aufheben
falls wirklich noch was schwieriges kommt
ok, buffen wir uns nochmal
ach, Lindsay hat ihr Zeug schon an
so, und jetzt bleibt mein Held mal hinten
und lässt die anderen das machen
generell ist bleibt der, der und der
und der
die bleiben hinten
ne, du auch hinter
du auch hinter
und Tristan auch hinter
so, jetzt kann da eigentlich nichts mehr passieren
wisst ihr, jetzt kriegen sie noch eine Runde
Haste von mir
Moment, Max, was machst du wieder da vorne
Alter, geh weg
mit F, ich dachte, ich hab den hinter geschickt
so, eine Runde Haste
und dann wird gebashed
ich bin auch echt, ich bin richtig bescheuert
warum hab ich meinen Held nicht
ich dachte, ich hab den hinter geschickt
richtig dämlich
so, Max, hinter
gut
hinter
Haste
gut, wäschen
geht doch
wisst ihr, jetzt ist überhaupt kein Ding mehr
jetzt kriegen sie auch sack
wenn für was hat man Tanks
wenn sie nicht tanken
so, wisst ihr
kaum macht man das richtig, ist überhaupt kein Problem
ok, hier gehts rauf
da liegt was
Lor braucht das
oh, das gehört zur Quest
gut zu wissen
vielleicht ist hier noch was
sollen wir uns hier aufpassen
nix mehr da
gut, gehen wir hier hoch
Hexenmeister, der Frontleiter
da hat er eigentlich gar nichts zu suchen, weil laut Format
hat er eigentlich gar nichts zu suchen, weil laut Format
Hexenmeister, der Frontleiter
da hat er eigentlich gar nichts zu suchen, weil laut Format
soll er hinten sein
und Valery soll vor
irgendwie hat das das Ding
irgendwie hat es das ein bisschen umgestellt
der soll hinter, der soll hinter, die soll ein bisschen in die Mitte
für Aura, der soll auch ein bisschen in die Mitte
für Aura
du kannst im Prinzip eigentlich auch vor
da hältst du ja ein bisschen was aus
und der Wolf soll auch vor
gar nicht, wer sich, was das Game mit meiner Formation
angestellt hat
Formation 0, ich würde mal sagen, das Game hat meine Formation
irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt gemacht, oder?
das ist auch
eines der wenigen Negativpunkte, wo ich sagen kann
die würde ich
die würde ich so unterschreiben bei dem Game
das hat ein paar Bugs
das ist okay
das lasse ich mir gefallen
aber ansonsten, was die Leute
da so schreiben, ist vollkommen
gescheuert
einmal Bar 4, Barbrage
an
Barzong
Max, du gehst jetzt mal ein bisschen
hinter, dass du nichts abkriegst
Clary geht auch ein bisschen
hinter
wie viel Haste-Ladung haben wir noch?
drei
gucken wir, ob wir das brauchen noch
die kriegen aber echt dicke auf den Sack gerade
so, mein Clary geht mal da rein
und macht da eh hier
es ruckelt, warum ruckelt das?
au!
alter, die Dinge hauen aber auch rein
ich will bloß mein
Elektroresi-Dings noch nicht verschwenden
fuck, ich hab scheiße gespeichert
okay, da muss der Clary gleich rein und heilen
ja, Max, mach doch mal Haste, komm
das kann nicht schaden
alter, die kriegt aber auf den Sack
heilen
heilen, heilen
der war nicht im Range zum heilen
na, auch geil
mein Mammut macht es jetzt
Mammut und Master Race
zack, jetzt, komm
der hält nicht mehr viel aus, der braucht ein paar Spells, dann ist er down
Clary, heilen
zack
Gott sei Dank, er
ja
zum Glück hat mein Clary so viel Heal
ich bin froh, wenn ich dieses Negative Level weg hab
wir können noch einmal hier heilen
oh nein, die heilt halt nix auf die Tanks
okay, was gibt's denn hier oben?
Loot
sinnlose Schriftrollen
und irgendwelche Kochzutaten
okay
hier geht's wieder runter
okay, mal gucken, was hier in der Mitte gibt
Treppe rauf
man muss halt sagen, das Spiel fühlt sich wirklich an wie
so die ganzen RPGs
wann kam Baldur's Gate raus?
2003 oder irgendwie so?
wann war denn das?
war noch ein bisschen früher, ich weiß gar nicht
98, fuck
und das Zweier
warte mal, das Zweier kam
2000, oh, das ist echt
das hätt ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht
so, hier oben geht's anscheinend nicht weiter
Rüstung
oh, eine Plattenrüstung plus 2
das ist nice, das ist super
das ist super
Plattenrüstung plus 2, das ist nice
das ist besser als das, was ich hab
Plattenrüstung plus 2
35 hat sie jetzt
und dann hat sie 36 Rüstungsklassen
das ist übelst gut
guck mal, da stellt sich einer rum
Wissencheck
erfolgreich
das Raum befindet sich
eingeschlossen, das Portal
wer hätte das gedacht?
das hätt ich jetzt ohne einen Wissencheck
natürlich nicht erkannt
ich glaube, ich muss mit dem Typ
fighten
man muss mit fast allen NPCs kämpfen
die rumstehen, mit denen man Dialogoptionen hat
deswegen
wir verteilen schon mal
unsere Pets und Tanks
so, dass das was bringt
wir müssen seinen Song anschmeißen
der Ranger geht ein Stückchen weg
ich muss zu dem Typ hin, weil ich mit ihm reden muss
was für meinen Held nicht gerade gut ist
und der Clary macht schon mal
macht schon mal einen Buff an
wir speichern mal
und dann reden wir mit dem Typ
wer seid ihr?
ich bin nicht so scharf darauf
das jetzt vorzulesen, weil eigentlich
wollte ich ja so weiterspielen
wie ich eh schon den ganzen Tag gespielt habe
nämlich
ihr wisst ja, ich spiele solche Games
auch wenn ich totaler
Roleplay-Fan bin
ich spiele solche
ich spiele sowas immer ohne großartige
Geschichten zu lesen
das ist Cringe, da hast du recht Patrick
ich mag das auch nicht
ich klicke immer so ungefähr durch
verzauber mal das Heiligtum, jawoll
aha, da steht jetzt Ironie davor
für die Leute, die sich checken, oder?
ihr Lichter, was machen die ihr Lichter hier?
bla bla bla, uninteressant
das heißt, dieser Ort sei verflucht
hm, woran könnte das wohl liegen?
Innschriften
ich hab genug
wir bringen ihn mal nicht gleich um
ich meine, er hat ja noch nichts gemacht
wo sind die anderen, die hierher kamen?
aha, alle weg
ihr seid nicht bei klarem Verstand
ja, das würde ich auch so sehen
oh, dafür gab es sogar XP
war anscheinend die richtige Antwort
eigentlich, es gab XP, weil ich einen
Religionswissen
erfolgreich absolviert habe
ihr solltet euch reden hören
ich hab auf der Insel eine Leiche gefunden
ja
ihr solltet euch mal selbst hören
ok, es gibt XP
XP ist nice, über XP sag ich nichts dagegen
ich werde euch im Kampf gegen das Monster beistehen
welches Monster?
Text lesen, FTW
egal, ich bin
gesinnungsmäßig bin ich ja
gut, das heißt natürlich werde ich
im Kampf gegen das Monster beistehen
wir wissen nichts über die Kreatur
die uns auf der anderen
gibt mir Zeit mich vorzubereiten
ja, muss ich vorbereiten
das ist ja komplett overrated
bashen müssen wir
so, siehste?
gut, dass wir pre-buffed haben
dann ist das hoffe ich mal
kann man speichern?
dann ist das hoffentlich kein Problem
hoffentlich kein Problem
man sieht ja nicht viel, weil da mein Mammut
den Kopf davor hat
also wir greifen nicht das Gehirn von meinem Mammut an
auch wenn es so aussieht
der kann sich mal buffen mit
Quatsch, der muss sich nicht buffen
mein Held muss auf jeden Fall sich mal hier verpissen
soviel ist sicher
siehste?
das ist der Wahnsinn
die fokussen
alle voll meinen Held
die sollen nicht meinen Held fokussen, weil
dann ist das Spiel vorbei
wenn mein Held was abkriegt
Clary heilt
guck mal hier was der für einen
Damage macht auf mich
zum Glück habe ich ganz gute Resies
alter
was die für einen Damage auf meinen Held macht
ist er down?
ich glaube er ist down
er ist down
gibt es in dem Game Lootboxen?
ja
es gibt Lootboxen, ganz viele
über die ganze Spielwelt verteilt
aber keine Echtgeld Lootboxen
Echtgeld Lootboxen
wir haben ihn gebashed
was hat er dabei gehabt?
Flöte des Zypressen
der Zypressen Königin
ein Experte
für Antiquitäten Fände ist sicher interessant
625 Gold
nehmen wir mit
so was machen wir mit dem Dude hier jetzt?
erstmal voll heilen
so safe
was können wir mit dem Typ jetzt machen?
seid ihr sicher, dass ihr auf der Insel bleiben wollt?
ja
könnt ihr dieses Portal verschließen?
nein, kann er nicht
er wäre ja auch was
die Einheimischen, ob die Insel seid, verflucht
das würde ich jetzt auch so sehen
ihr seid eine Gefahr für euch selbst, andere
macht was ihr wollt
ich weiß nicht, also eigentlich gibt es ja keinen Grund
ihn jetzt irgendwie zu killen, ne?
er hat uns ja sogar jetzt gerade geholfen
im Kampf gegen dieses Viech
allerdings, wenn wir ihn killen, dann können wir ihn looten
was wollen wir machen, wollen wir ihn killen oder wollen wir ihn leben lassen?
er hat bestimmt kein gescheites Loot dabei
er hat bestimmt irgendwie keine Ahnung
irgendwie Gürtel plus eins
oder irgendwie sowas, was
was eh schon, was jeder
von mir an hat
macht was ihr wollt
was für eine Gesinnung ich spiele
ich bin neutral gut
also eigentlich kann ich ihn nicht killen
einfach so, wenn es danach geht
aber das ist ja
weil das Game teilweise merkwürdige
Dialogoptionen hat
ist das keine Gesinnungsantwort
also das zählt nicht
auch wenn es bescheuert ist
also eigentlich müsste das hier
eine Gesinnungsantwort sein, dass ich halt
über eine Gesinnung verrutsche oder so, aber
ist es nicht
aber ich bringe ihn nicht um
warum auch, ne?
ich könnte ihn immer noch killen
ich will ihn aber nicht killen
gehen wir mal gucken, was gibt es denn hier sonst noch so
gehen wir außen lang
da ist ein bisschen mehr Platz, da kann man Held
auch weiter hinten stellzen
ja, Held soll weg
weiter weg
Moment, mein Held soll weg
und dann rennen wir als erstes
wie viele sind denn von dem Kram noch hier
das ist ja schlimm
Haste
Barzong
haben wir noch
wir müssten doch eigentlich noch
haben wir noch hier
Gebet, Action
Clary darf einfach heilen
und er darf Haste
casten
falls er es nicht schon gemacht hat
Haste, Haste, jawoll
und jetzt hier weghauen
oh, da sind vier Stück
Alter, was geht mit dem Wolf ab
der macht den 260 Kreiselcopter
okay
mein Ranger macht das, was er kann
Bogenschießen
gut ist
der könnte einmal
Clary macht noch einen
Buff
und ich caste einfach mit drauf
und dann ist gut
wollen wir alle eh
healen
ja, das war jetzt nicht so schwierig
oh, hier
Wissen zu check
diese checks sind ganz praktisch, wenn man die macht
nicht unbedingt, weil man jetzt hier die tolle Lore lesen will
sondern einfach weil es XP gibt
danach müssen wir unbedingt in die Hauptstadt
wir haben doch noch einmal
haben wir gar nicht benutzt
Schutz vor Elektrizität
zack, jetzt können sie nichts mehr
jetzt werden sie geschreckt
guck mal, ich muss gar nichts machen
Hände vor der Tastatur weg
mit Elektroresi haben die überhaupt keine Chance
vielleicht sollte ich einfach
wenn die Map noch groß ist
ich glaube es ja nicht, dass die Map noch so groß ist
aber vielleicht sollte ich einfach
mehr, noch einen dritten
Elektroresi spell ausrüsten
weil dann können die Dinge überhaupt nichts mehr machen
Essbares Moos
da freue ich mich schon den ganzen Tag drauf
schön veganes Moos
das wär bestimmt auch was für Unge
obweiler, das war ja Milch
ich hab's ja ganz vergessen
Schwerer Schild, was haben wir hier
Zwergenschild der Annen
Schwerer Schild plus 2 Gewerzeinträger
also für einen Kläri
nicht für ihn als Kläri
sondern für den Zwergenkläri
den ich noch hab
ziemlich gute Schild
haben wir hier noch was
Loot
was ich übrigens toll finde in dem Game
kann man Mammut looten
guck ich zeig's euch mal
also wer schon immer mal sehen wollte wie das aussieht
wenn man Mammut looted
so sieht das aus
das wird jetzt
bestes Mammut
feines Mammut
ein nicees Mammut
oder was sagt ihr
das ist schon ein sehr nicees Mammut finde ich
ich glaub die Map ist zu Ende
an der Stelle hier
aber ihr habt jetzt ja die Map gesehen
von der Größe her ungefähr
so groß sind alle Maps
also alle Gebiete wo man rein kann
es gibt auch welche die sind kleiner
es gibt welche die sind eine ganze Ecke größer
aber im Durchschnitt würde ich sagen
sind die Gebiete ungefähr so groß hier
und ihr habt die Weltkarte gesehen
also man hat extrem viel zu tun
man sollte dem niceen Mammut
ein Leckerli geben
das ist natürlich auch
die allseits bekannte
natürliche Ernährung
von Mammuts
was jetzt tatsächlich so war
ich weiß halt nicht ob die
Moos gefressen haben
aber die haben
was weiß ich
Steinzeitmoos oder so
ah Moment
das ist die Stelle wo ich früher
vorher drüber springen konnte
ah wenn ich
ok also wenn ich hier drüber gesprungen wäre
wäre ich hier rausgekommen das heißt dann probieren wir jetzt mal auf dem
Rückweg rüber zu springen
hat funktioniert nice
und gibt EXP
da müssen wir den anderen auch noch ausprobieren
ne es geht nur einmal
so Quest
finished
was wir leider nicht geschafft haben
ist das verschwundene Kind zu finden
hier
das ist blöd
nachdem wir jetzt eh rasten
können wir mal den restlichen
Haste
hallo bleibst du hier
können wir mal den restlichen Haste Zauber noch verschwenden
dass wir schneller
zurückkommen
zum Anlegepunkt
Mammuts haben bis vor 12.000 Jahren
in Sibirien
ist das so
mein Chat ist so intelligent
es ist einfach
umwerfend
das ist komplett
brain
was ist hier los
oh gehen
Quest fertig
next
ich bin auch in Act 2
das liegt einfach daran weil ich meinen Quest noch nicht weiter gemacht habe
sondern erst mal Map erkundet habe
und ich hab es euch ja gerade gezeigt
die Map ist riesengroß wie man hier sieht
und
ich glaube die MainQuest geht
weiter wenn man das hier macht
eine verdiente Belohnung
das sieht für mich so HauptQuest aus weil das gab es
bei der MainQuest einfach deswegen denke
dass es halt da weiter geht
so wir müssen jetzt mal
schnell zurück in die Hauptstadt weil ich muss
mein Level heilen
so wenn wir in der Hauptstadt waren da kann ich euch
mal gleich diesen
wir es mal wirtschafts
Part des Games zeigen
und dann gehen wir in die Hütte
der Sumpfwechsel und gucken uns das
Exenmenschendorf unten an und gucken mal ob wir
irgendwie den Junge finden der von
daheim weg gerannt ist
so wir gehen natürlich in den
Thronsaal
weil woanders können wir nichts machen
in der Stadt
und gucken mal was es
Neues gibt
Baron Max muss ja auch mal
seine Aufgaben erledigen
na so Baron da muss
Schadschor was zu tun
auf allem Untergebene rumkommandieren
das ist ganz wichtig
so und natürlich sitzt auch
mein Mammut auf dem Thron
geh weg
mein Mammut macht das jetzt
mein Mammut wird jetzt das Königreich für mich verwalten
weil das
ist absolut Big Brain Mammut haben wir ja gesehen
mit 2 Int kann da nichts schiefgehen
ok Projekte was ist
fertig ist irgendwas fertig
Straße endet in 9 Tagen
ahja also so mal zur Erklärung
das hier ist so dieser Wirtschaftspart von dem Game
es gibt halt irgendwelche auf man hat hier
man hat Ratgeber
den kann man verschiedene Positionen
zuweisen was ist er erstmal General
für Militär und sonst was und man kann auch
mehrere Ratgeber freischalten
und
ab und zu kommen
halt irgendwelche Ereignisse wie Spinnenplagen
und sonst was die kann ich
dann
zuordnen
einer der Berater der dir das erledigen soll
und dann klappt es oder klappt es nicht
und da
kann ich halt noch weiter mein Königreich ausbauen
neue Städte gründen da habe ich
meine Hauptstadt hier oben habe ich irgendwie noch
ein paar Ressourcen erobert dann habe ich hier noch eine andere
Stadt gegründet
also es ist ganz gut gemacht
es ist jetzt kein SimCity oder so
das ist so für nebenbei
wenn man keinen Bock mehr hat auf Monster klatschen dann
macht man das mal ein bisschen
so was
gibt es denn hier neues
du machst das jetzt
kostet 100 Punkte
haben wir auch Lösungsdauer 60 Tage
heute ewig
Moment diese Quest
haben wir gerade gelöst
vielleicht kann ich die Quest mit dem Junge
ja auch nur lösen wenn ich hier den
Kram erforschen lasse
da müssen wir mal gucken
ok Handel kann ich mir nicht leisten
kostet 1500 Punkte und ich habe
das ist nichts
Moins Relax
also das taugt nichts
ähm forschen
ich will halt den Berater nicht ungenutzt
lassen
das kostet aber auch so viel
komm dann darf der
dann darf der jetzt hier einfach mal dran forschen
um gut ist
was denn jetzt überhaupt
wo ist denn jetzt
seh ichs jetzt nicht
forschen
ach hier
forsche mal Kollege
und ich hau wieder ab
und mach meine Quest weiter
weil ich will mich nicht zu sehr um
mein
Königreich da
Wirtschaftssimulationsmäßig kümmern
ich will eher Monster
Monster wollen gebashed werden
ja und was ich nicht vergessen darf
ich muss meine
mein Negativlevel heilen
was muss man bei dem Spiel machen
hast du mal Baldur's Gate
Icewind Dale oder
äh Divinity
Original Sim gespielt
dann muss man hier das gleiche machen
Monster killen
Quests erledigen und wahrscheinlich
ich weiß noch nicht genau wohin
die Hauptstory geht werden wir gleich noch sehen
ähm
ja
Welt retten wahrscheinlich
was
Evoli ernsthaft
ernsthaft
das glaube ich dir nicht
Evoli du debaters mich jetzt gerade
wo ist denn der Clary
der die Scrolls verkauft
was Triaxe wurde gebannt
von Twitch
das ist der ernsthaft
das muss ich jetzt nachgucken
das ist so eines der Ur Twitch
Typen schlechthin
der wurde wirklich gebannt
the fuck
wat
was
warum
warte mal Evoli hat
ne Link geschickt
Triaxe banned
all Twitch
was ist jetzt passiert
das ist doch nicht in
ihr ernst oder
warum
was
hä
was hat er denn gemacht
gemacht
Weil der fuck gesagt hat okay keine ahnung was was mit twitch wieder los ist
Aber ich meine ist das wieder was wo wo in den bot band und kein kein mensch drauf guckt oder was
Ich habe ich gucke relativ echt relativ oft die streams von tracks und
Da ist ja nichts irgendwie
anstößig oder
Ich also
So
Schriftrolle genesung das brauchen wir dann dann da kaufen wir auch gleich mal wie viel kostet der kram 840
Kaufen wir zwei stück
Mal gucken ob ich mal gucken ob ich mich selbst heilen darf oder ob das mein kläri machen muss
Vielleicht darf ich mich auch selbst heilen
Ach die macht das für mich easy perfekt
Und
Kommt das spiel an die winne die drei ich finde schon es ist halt es ist vom
Kampfsystem her und auch von der geschwindigkeit her es ist
Schon anders man kann das nicht so richtig so richtig vergleichen es ist beides
Relativ so klassische rpg kost ja aber das hier kommt deutlich mehr nach halt der pen and paper vorlage
Wieso hast du einen mammoth weil ich das gescald habe
Hier habe ich einen mammoth ich bin nämlich ein
Schütze einen waldhexen meister bin ich nämlich und als waldhexen meister kriegt man auf stufe eins
Ein animal companion und da habe ich den ich hier mammoth
Und das ist kein mammoth ist ein mastodon
Da muss man schon korrekt sein
So wir sind eigentlich fertig wir können wir können raus stufe geheilt
stufe geheilt runter
und weiter quest aber das kann ich mir echt nicht voll also das ist
Echt also trieckst zu bannen ist
Das ist so wie wenn du dense gaming bannen würdest das ist also es ist quasi so mit
Einer der freundlichsten allgemein verträglichsten streams ever bei ihm haben sie ja auch mal wegen dem emote damals rumgeschrien dass er angeblich irgendwie
Aber was haben sie bei ihm erzählt dass er irgendwie anti
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr
Dass er irgendwie gegen schwule ist oder so keine ahnung weil er den mode hatte
Die leute sind übertreibens heute ist man es ist wirklich heutzutage bei an jedem scheiß ist irgendeiner
offenden und stört sich
Und anstatt dass man sich dann irgendwann wieder beruhigt
Und schreien dann gleich noch 5000 andere mit
Da werden aus wirklich aus so vielen mücken elefanten gemacht heutzutage
Für mich nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt wo wir gerade beim thema sind so wir gehen jetzt
runter hier zur hütte der sumpfhexe und gucken wir was da ist weil warum ist warum warum es jetzt neue ereignisse gibt
Habt ihr das in russland mitgekriegt mit der ein feministin die durch die u-bahnen gegangen ist und
die leute mit zeug angesprüht hat
angeschüttet hat
oh stopp
Resting ist für nukes
Kann ich das nicht claim also das befindet sich nicht auf meinem land
Das erklärt
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt? Ja komm ist gut wir rasten. Habt ihr das mitgekriegt mit der in der u-bahne?
Auch wieder richtig richtig hängen geblieben
Essen verkackt
Brauchen wir eh nicht das hier gibt es kaum random encounter
Und wenn sind sie einfach
naja also
Die leute angesprüht das habe ich falsch ausgedrückt die ist die gibt es auch auf youtube das video das ist irgendeine russische
feministin gewesen die ist quasi wegen die ist durch die u-bahnen gelaufen weil er männer
in der u-bahnen quasi immer mit breiten beinen da sitzen
nicht etwa weil das ich meine manche übertreiben ja keine frage aber
Feministen sind ja der ansicht männer sitzen nicht aus
anatomischen gründen
mit bisschen
breiteren beinen da sondern um
quasi männliche dominanz über die frau auszustrahlen das nennt sich dann men's spreading dass es dafür schon wieder worte gibt das tut das tut
allein schon beim aussprechen wieder wehe
Und deswegen ist sie durch die u-bahnen gelaufen hat sich gedacht sie muss jetzt mal
der war vorher nicht da
Sie muss jetzt den männer mal eine lektion erteilen dass sie sich jetzt mal eine lektion
erteilen dass das ja so nicht geht da überall in der u-bahnen zu mentsprennen
dass das geht das ist ja nicht drin und da hat sie sich irgendwie in gemisch in so eine flasche gefüllt aus ich
Ich weiß nicht irgendwas ätzendes
Irgendwas ätzendes hat sie in die flasche gefüllt ja jetzt ich also ich weiß ich ob es seure war oder so
Und da ist sie dann wirklich durch die u-bahnen gelaufen und hat
Männern hier diese flüssigkeit in den schritt gekippt
muss ich mir mal vorstellen
Und die ist auch noch der meinung sie ist absolut im recht
Weil die männer ja mentspredet haben
Also sie hat ja auch anscheinend keine
irgendwie jetzt
Schuldgefühle oder oder unrecht bewusst sein oder so sie ist der meinung dass hat das gehört den ja auch nicht besser wenn sie
Mentsprennen in der u-bahnen vorstellt so weit sind wir im jahr 2018. Ja alter
Als mich wundern ist dass da keiner eine reingehauen hat
Wenn ich mir angucke was für leute bei uns in der u-bahnen sitzen
Die sich wegen jedem scheiß ab und zu mal kloppen dass da nichts passiert ist wundert mich echt
Ja es ist es ist einfach hängen geblieben ja das die fühlt sich halt auch absolut im recht
Ich hoffe die wird jetzt mal zumindest ein bisschen zur weiß nicht was einem da passieren kann wenn man sowas macht in russland keine
Ahnung oder auch hier man
Es ist halt schon die frage zumindest mal versuchte körperverletzungen vielleicht oder so
Aber
War doch immer selbst bescheuert aber so weit sind wir schon
Banditen banditen wollen gebashed werden banditen schüchtern wir nicht ein und schicken sie weg
Sondern wir bashen die
Ja
Die können nix
Alter
Guckt euch jetzt mal an so nuller 15 banditen wie schnell die umkippen im vergleich zu den
Zu den ehrlichtern auf der insel die werden ja geschreckt
Was dabei hier unten was dabei
100 gold
armbrust sagt sonst was boge
50 gold brauche ich alles nicht safe ja
Aber ich habe ich auch wieder gedacht was ist denn mit der welt los heutzutage wieder
Ich meine man kann es echt übertreiben man kann es wirklich komplett übertreiben
Und sowas führt ja auch nicht dazu dass man sich so ein bisschen übertreiben kann
Das ist wirklich komplett übertreiben und sowas führt ja auch nicht dazu dass jetzt irgendwie
Weiß nicht die die die leute sagen so oh ja jetzt habe ich den fehler ja eingesehen ich sollte anders in der u-bahn da sitzen oder so
Das führt eigentlich zu zu noch mehr körper einschlagen gegenseitig ins quest will bücher drucken und irgendwie ist das zeug für
So ein bücher drucken da in dem wagen anscheinend was wollt ihr drucken was schönes drucken genau
Und wenn wir gerade hier sind ich erinnere mich nämlich dass hier oben auf der map das letzte mal wo ich hier war
Waren übelschwere gegner und mal gucken ob wir die jetzt schaffen
Schreckt habe ich schon lange ich sage das eigentlich ganz gerne gerade weil es irgendwie keiner mehr sagt
Das ist genauso wie und uns sagt auch kaum noch einer was heute sagen sie alle recht
Dabei war früher und oder pound oder sonst war es viel
Alltäglicher viel normaler ja auch heute sagt das keiner mehr ist komplett old school wenn er das heute noch sagt wer sagt heute noch und
Außer die robbe die robbe sagt das immer noch
So die dinger sehen zwar nicht so aus allerdings ist der mächtige wütende eulenbär
Der auch tatsächlich so aussieht
Übels starker gegner der hat mich das letzte mal zuschottet
Okay, mal gucken mal gucken ob wir die jetzt ob wir das jetzt packen ich speichere mal aber ich war das letzte mal hier mit level
Sechs oder so und ich wurde komplett zerstört das heißt ich könnte mir vorstellen diese dinger sind jetzt auch noch ein bisschen zu schwer
Man weiß ja nicht
Ist
Gucken wir mal
Tristan darf mal
Feuerball drauf ballern
Und ich schießt mal magic missiles drauf
Und lindsey kann mal versuchen irgendwie was einzuschläfern oder so
Fuck das hat nicht, oh die nehmen überhaupt keinen damage alter
Okay, das wird ein vibe das wird ein vibe ich sag's euch
Das wird ein vibe das wird ein vibe ich sag's euch
Alter
Okay, halt die außen mich komplett die außen mich komplett die bär
Oh fuck
Okay, ich glaube ich muss trotzdem später noch mal wieder kommen
Hey, wie geht's eigentlich dem kabin was treibt eigentlich so das weiß ich nicht habe ich schon eine weile nichts mehr gehört
Kann ich dir nicht sagen
Ja
Gut was geht was geht eigentlich mit dem haase ab ist das zweiköpfige haase hier
Für den geglittschter haase
Oder wie sagt aporetten immer ein kritischer haase ist das hier gibt's den eigentlich noch
Ewig ewig nix mehr empfohlen bekommen auf youtube interessiert mich aber auch nicht
So wir können gibt's irgendwie eine taktik wie wir die hier angehen können ich mein
So wie ich das hier sehe ist sind hier büsche das heißt hier kommt eigentlich
Nix ran
Das heißt ich stelle mal meine helden alle auf hold position
Dann wird gebufft dann haut amiri ab und valerie bleibt vorne weil valerie mir aushält defensiv haltung
Okay, dann baffen wir uns noch mal und mal gucken mal gucken ob das ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert
Okay barb rage
Buffen
Buffen einfach einfach alles buffen alles buffen okay habe ich noch irgendwas zum buffen
Erstmal nicht
Ich weiß was zu tun
Hier mein freund das dann damage machen
Hoffentlich hoffentlich macht es ordentlich damage ja das macht überhaupt keinen schaden
Aber wir hätten auch die waffe buffen können von valerie machen wir jetzt noch
Ja also wir kasten jetzt einfach magic missiles drauf bis es kaputt geht
Was amiri hau ab was machst du da vorne ich hab dich auf hold position gestellt btf
Soll das ja
Ich glaube aber das wird nichts die dinger dürften noch ein bisschen zu stark sein
Wir könnten hier noch mal versuchen zu planten mit lindsey
Die dinger machen zu viel damage das wird nix
Ja wobei also das mit ein bisschen glück ein bisschen glück könnte das tatsächlich was werden
Ich weiß was ich jetzt mal machen kann
Ist er down? Nein
Ich kann sagen die kampfmusik ist irgendwie weg ne die hat keinen bop mehr
overrated, she baited
Valery könnte man mal heilen lassen
Fuck
Ok, Valarie ist so gut wie down
Wenn die jetzt noch einmal Damage kriegt
Dann ist vorbei
Ja, super
Jetzt ist sie tot
Ok, die Dinger sind noch...
Wie die Dinger meine Tanks zerlegen
Das ist ja nicht normal
Aber
Also man könnte es schaffen
Also von der
Taktik her ist das glaube ich gar nicht so schlecht
Komm einmal probier was noch
Von der Taktik her war das gar nicht so blöd
Das Problem war, dass Amiri wieder losgelaufen
ist und keinen Bock hatte hinten zu bleiben
Leider ja, den gibt es noch
Ok, jetzt hätte mich auch gewohnt, wenn es nicht mehr gäbe
Schonmal vier Accountnamen geändert
Tja
Gibt ein paar
Gibt ein paar, die in
Also habe ich schon öfters in Kommentaren gelesen
Die so nach dem Motto dann schreiben
Max kennst du noch x, y und sonst was
War mal ein Account von 2011
Ok, hold position
Hold position
Eigentlich ist es so nicht schlecht
Defensive fight
Open to your orders
Ok, wir buffen jetzt noch
Wir probieren es jetzt noch einmal aus
Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann
Lassen wir es
Ok
Haben wir noch, haben wir noch irgendwas zu buffen
Ja, Walri kriegt noch
Rüstungsbuff
Dann haben wir noch, haben wir noch irgendwas
Ja Walri, kommen noch mehr Rüstungsbuff
Äh
Blessingsbuff, alles, alles wird alles
Gebufft jetzt, alles was geht
Ok, das war es, mehr geht glaube ich
Echt nicht
Und Max sollte mal da vorne weg
Gibt es jetzt noch Haste
Fertig
Und jetzt wird gepullt
Gepullt mit Magic Missle
Und mit Fireball
Und mit
Bung
Wir könnten Walri nochmal hier
Max, du sollst
Stehen bleiben
Stehen bleiben und casten
Und nicht so komisch rumrennen hier
Ähm
Das da machen wir jetzt noch
Du sollst da drauf schießen
Da drauf schießen
Und du sollst
Hier nochmal ein Fireball drauf schießen
Wunderbar
Ja
Und jetzt hoffen wir, dass das irgendwie klappt
Aber vielleicht, warte mal
Vielleicht kann Lindsay noch das Mammut heilen
Oh nein, das Mammut ist down
Fuck
Die Dinger machen zu viel Damage
Das geht nicht
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice
Hier nochmal Damage
Aber Lindsay könnte den Wolf heilen
Lindsay, heil mal den Wolf
Lindsay, scheiß auf den Wolf
Mach, heil mal Walri
Die Kampfmusik haut immer ab
Warum?
Ok, der Clary heilt
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr nice
Der erste Bär ist down
Sehr schön
Erster Bär ist down
Nächster da drauf
Lindsay darf jetzt
Kann ja eh nichts casten, kann weiter angreifen
Der greift den auch an
Walri bleibt hier stehen und haut zurück
Amiri macht nichts, weil die stirbt sonst instant
Auf
Der Kreiselbär ist am Start
Nice, nice, nice, das könnte echt was werden
Das könnte echt was werden
Oh nee, ah Amiri, geh weg
Piss dich, alte
Komm mal hier, ein Treffer fast down
Überhaupt keine, überhaupt keine Ausdauer
Nein, nein Amiri, du sollst hinten bleiben
Ok, das wird was, das wird was
Call Peter, ja
Nice
Gebashed, wrecked
Siehste Leute, mit der ordentlichen Taktik
Und den ordentlichen Buffs
Funktioniert das alles
Und die Gegner haben jetzt wirklich reingehauen wie sonst was
Hatte ich nicht noch kritische Wunden heilen?
Und so?
Hatte ich
Warum hab ich das nicht auf der Leiste?
Kacknoob
Sehr schön
So
Oh jetzt müssen wir wirklich Peter anrufen
Mammut RIP
Wolf hat es überlebt
Und der Hase hat sich entbackt
Das ist doch schön
Oh
Nix Scheiß
Da Mammut ist tot weil ich ihm das essbare Moos gegeben habe
Ein Duellschwert
Ich hab keinen der das tragen kann
Auch toll
Ein plus zwei
Behändiges Duellschwert plus zwei
Ich hab keinen Charakter der das gebrauchen kann
Aber die Beeren haben
Glaube ich war ziemlich ordentlich
XP gegeben oder?
Ja 240 ist sehr sehr ordentlich
Ja
Es ist ordentlich
So jetzt haben wir hier alles gemacht
Jetzt können wir wieder zurück
Und damit wir schneller zurück sind werde ich mal wieder ein Haste Spell raushauen
Codstream wenn es rauskommt
Weil ich echt noch am überlegen bin wegen Black Ops 4
Ob ich misshole
Weil im Prinzip finde ich Black Ops nicht schlecht
Ich habe aber so meine Bedenken wie gut das auf dem PC sein wird
Gar nicht mal so sehr dass es nicht läuft oder so
Also man muss ja sagen zu Black Ops es sah auf dem PC für ein Game in 2018 ziemlich kacke aus
Das muss man einfach jetzt mal sehen und auch irgendwie akzeptieren
Die Optik alleine macht es zwar nicht aus
Wenn es dann am wenigsten mit 300 FPS läuft wie Overwatch okay
Aber ich bin generell skeptisch wie das läuft auf dem PC mit Cod
Weil die sind ja bekannt dafür dass sie ihre Games keinen sonnig guten Anti-Cheat einbauen auf dem PC
Ich weiß noch wie sie sich damals darüber beschwert haben dass sie ja keinen Anti-Cheat machen können
Das war zu MW3 oder so
Da haben sie sich darüber beschwert wir können ja gar keinen Anti-Cheat machen
Weil Steam unterstützt ja bloß 32-Bit Anti-Cheat
Und wir sind so modern und unser Game ist viel besser und deswegen bräuchten wir einen 64-Bit Anti-Cheat
Und deswegen können wir leider keinen Anti-Cheat machen
Ich bin ein bescheuerter Ausredner
Und deswegen weiß ich nicht wie gut das laufen wird auf dem PC ehrlich gesagt
Ja das ist so meine Bedenken die ich habe bei Blackout
So haben wir unsere Quest jetzt fertig
Verschwundene Kind haben wir noch nicht gefunden
Okay abgeschiedene Hütte
Dann gehen wir jetzt
Gehen wir jetzt zur abgeschiedenen Hütte oder gehen wir jetzt zum Dorf des Echsenvolks
Ich würde sagen wir gehen zum Dorf des Echsenvolks weil da könnte durchaus sein dass wir den Junge aus der Stadt finden den wir suchen
Aber ich denke auch mal dass ich also ich gehe mal davon aus dass ich mir Black Ops 4 holen werde
Lull ein Echsenwensch
Blablabla es gibt XP das ist schon mal schön
Ah guck mal ja ich suche ein Verschwundene Kind aha anscheinend kann man wirklich die Quest weiter machen
Dein Stamm ist mir ehrlich gesagt vollkommen wurscht
Im Dorf noch am Leben
Sehr schön
Ja dann klicken wir mal die die anderen Optionen durch weil man ja keine Gesprächsmöglichkeiten verpassen will
Geh weiter zack
Ja das ist halt der Weg wie ich RPGs spiele
Ich lese es relativ wenig durch vor allem weil mir halt die Mannschaft nicht gut ist
Ich lese es relativ wenig durch vor allem weil mir halt die meisten Texte so übelst lange an mich vorkommen
So und jetzt denn hier weiter
Ok da unten ist das Dorf checken wir das mal ab ob es hier irgendwie Loot gibt oben
Siehst du da ist schon was
Wir müssen auch mal hätten wir eigentlich den Hauptstand machen können hätten wir es sellen können
Ich habe so viel Trash Loot was ich verkaufen kann
Ja aber nächste Woche oder wann ist denn
Fuck
Ein mächtiger Varan
Ok die können bestimmt nichts
Almiri Rage Mode an und Bashen
Äh Moment Max Max Max langsam
Du sollst das nicht als sollst das hier als Auto Angriff verwenden
Ähm
Ach
Die können alle nichts werden alle gebashed muss man nichts casten
Heuten einsammeln Peter anrufen
Hext
Kann man hier rum
Ok es geht anscheinend weiter hier
Aber
Nicht an der Stelle
Warte mal her
Wir checken jetzt erstmal die Umgebung ab bevor wir ins Dorf gehen
Ok
Übrigens dieses automatische Wegfindersystem in dem Game ist teilweise ein bisschen verbackt
Ich hatte das schon mal da habe ich hier irgendwie oben auf die Map geklickt
Und auf einmal sind meine Helden quasi out of Map gelaufen hier außen rum zu dem Punkt
Habe ich auch gedacht das ist bestimmt so nicht gedacht
Mehr Loot
Zeug was Geld bringt
Auch gut
Ah kann man hier runter?
Naja kann man nicht
Kann man auch nicht lang
Das ist ja blöd
Aber hier geht es gar nicht weiter
Oh
Jetzt geht es hier oben lang
Man sieht nicht wirklich was
Man sieht es ist gedacht dass ich zuerst ins Dorf gehe bevor ich hier oben rumlaufe
Hallo
Ich sehe nichts
Ich sehe nichts Game
Please
Ok hier geht es nicht weiter
Ein Gift
Hodak
Ein unsichtbarer Gift Hodak
Ich muss übrigens rasten dass ich meinen Mammut wieder kriege
Wäschen
Ähm ja
Und vielleicht sollte ich dem Clary mal abgewöhnen automatisch Heals zu casten
Das verbraucht ein bisschen viel Ladung
Also mein Mammut ist nicht tot
Mein Mammut muss ähm
Ich muss rasten dass mein Mammut wieder kommt
Ach das war gelockt
Was haben wir hier auch
Schattenmantel gewährt
Den ver
Oh das ist nice
Das können wir Lindsay geben
Oder wir geben es ihm aber ich gebe es mal Lindsay
Lindsay ist so mein
Stellcharakter
Moment ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt
Hat es, hat der Rüst, der Umhang
Nee brauchste nicht
Dann kriegt sie den Schattenumhang an
Ja weil so einen richtigen Rogue habe ich nicht
Ich hab ähm
So einen, so einen, so einen
Rogue-Hybrid-Ding
In der Hauptstadt
Das ist auch ganz nice
Aber man braucht das in Pathfinder
Pathfinder anscheinend gar nicht
Weil man kann mit jedem Charakter
Quasi die Sachen für Fallen
Also Fallen finden und Fallen entschärfen
Kann man mit jedem
Charakter quasi specken
Das heißt man braucht gar keinen Rogue
Man braucht keinen Rouge
Wir haben einen, so geil
Wir haben einen auf der Arbeit
Wir haben auch steif und feste Meinung
Dass der Film, dass es Rouge One heißt
Der Film
Und da hat sie nicht davon überzeugen lassen
Dass das nicht so ist
Was
Der Exenvolk Berserker
Alles weg bashen
Freund oder Feind
Krieg oder Frieden also wir sind diplomatisch
Wir sind auf jeden Fall diplomatisch
Weil wir haben plus 19 Diplomatie
Was heißt wir können diesen Check
Eigentlich gar nicht failen
Und würfeln dann aber das ist recht unwahrscheinlich
So einen einschüchtern müssen wir den auch nicht
Wir sind diplomatisch
Und Rationen bieten wir ihm auch nicht an
Weil ich nicht so viele Rationen dabei habe
Wir sind diplomatisch
Easy, so einfach ist das
Der Exenvolk König
Was will er denn
Ein kräftiger Exenmensch
Er ist mit dem Kopf größer als der Rest des Stamms
Es gibt ja
Easy, XP, easy, live
Ist ja umsonst
Was los, warmblut
Dein Stamm hält ein Menschenkind gefangen
Ich bin kaum das Kind mitzunehmen, jawoll
Ich möchte
Fragen will ich dich eigentlich nicht
Ich will das Kind wieder haben
Diplomatie
Okay, also
Wenn wir diesen Diplomativwurf jetzt failen
Dann ist Zeit zum uninstall
Wir brauchen Diplomatie
Und ich habe Diplomatie plus 19
Das bedeutet
Wir müssen eine 0 oder eine 1 würfeln
Von 20
Dass wir
Diesen Check
Failen
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht
Jawoll, okay, hat geklappt
Was du selbst
Sprechen mit großem Stammvater
Das machen wir
Äh, wer bist du
Erzähl mir von dem Stamm
Warum ist das
Ist mir vollkommen egal
Danke für die Antworten, angreifen
Nein, wir greifen nicht an
Wir gehen zur Hütte und sprechen
Mit dem großen Stammvater
Jawoll, das machen wir
Ich speicher mal, ich will mal testen
Ob diese Viecher sind
Ich speicher mal, ich greife den jetzt an
Ich will den nicht wirklich, ich will einfach mal gucken
Wie viele Dinge aushalten, angreifen
Äh, gegen die ist Feuerball bestimmt
Ganz toll
Oh Max, du stehst direkt vor dem Typ
Das ist keine gute Idee
Au, au, au
Die können ja gar nichts
Die können wir auch angreifen
Aber das machen wir nicht
Das machen wir nicht
Wir greifen die nicht an, weil
Oh, da kommen noch mehr
Aber zumindest können die nichts
Ich greife die nicht an, weil eigentlich
Ja, eigentlich bin ich ja
Gut
Ich wollte bloß testen, was die Gegner können
Ok, dann gehen wir jetzt den großen
Stammvater
In der Geisterhütte besuchen
Ich gebe zu, klingt nach ziemlich generic
RPG-Quest, ist es wahrscheinlich auch
Aber macht trotzdem Bock
Wie sollen wir da rein
Kann das sein, dass die Quest nicht
Aktualisiert hat?
Kann das sein, dass die Quest nicht aktualisiert hat?
Ich glaube, ich gehe da nochmal rein
Und frage den Anführer nochmal
Nicht, dass die Quest verpackt ist oder so
Ne, doch, die Quest hat aktualisiert
Steht bloß in dem Quest-Log
Ach gut
Who cares
So, gibt es hier irgendeinen Händler?
Ein bisschen Zeug kaufen
Ah, wir können looten
Nice Loot
Wir können, vor allem auch ganz wichtig
Wir können den Sack
Können wir holen
Looten
Ganz viel Loot
Da ist einer
Können wir bashen
Wir heilen, wir heilen ihn mal
Da kriegen wir bestimmt irgendwas für
Wer bist du, was ist passiert
Wie hast du mich
Neutral, gut
Wir heilen den nächsten Mensch
XP
Dann ist er wieder am Start
Dafür können wir jetzt auch deine Hütte looten, oder?
Wir haben dich geheilt, dafür looten wir die Hütte
Das ist doch fairer Austausch, würde ich sagen
Hier noch was
Looten
Was
Diplomatie, du scheinst Angst zu haben
Was ist hier los, Diplomatie ist gut
Diplomatie habe ich viel geskillt
Erfolgreich, jawoll
Lebt das Kind noch
Moment, kann ich den Typ jetzt überreden
Mir das Kind zu geben
Ohne dass ich die restliche Quest machen muss
Ne, ich glaube nicht, oder
Ich glaube das war einfach nur
Ein großes Gelaber
Ja
So, haben die irgendeinen Händler
In ihrem
In ihrem Dorf
Würde ich nämlich mal gerne gucken, was der so hat
Das Spiel ist interessant, das kostet ein paar Steamer aber ziemlich so viel
Dann holt sie doch bei GOG
Da kostet es nicht mehr, aber
Da kostet es auch nicht weniger
Aber es hat kein Steam-DHM oder so
Zeug drauf
Und
Ich bilde mir an, es gab sogar letztens bei GOG
Irgendeine Aktion für
Essbares Moos, hm
Endlich wieder
Und was haben wir hier Gemüse
Ja
Das ist ja für mich als Omnivore
Weißer
Mann, ist das ganz schlimm das hier Gemüse
Was haben wir hier
Was wollt ihr, worüber streitet ihr
Das ist mir, also eigentlich ist es mir egal
Aber ich muss die Dialogoption machen
Ähm
Zum Heilen falsch, Pflanzengrüne Kräuter
Falsch, blablabla, Stammvater
Zu dem wollen wir ja, zum großen Stammvater
Chaotisch gut
Ich bin
Das ist mir
Was auch immer, gut, jawoll
Easy
XP
Ok, die reden jetzt nicht mehr mit mir
Ach gut
So, haben wir gelootet
Erstmal den Gemüsegarten plündern
Ja, es ist egal
In so vielen RPGs kannst du in jede Hütte
reinlaufen, einfach jeden Schrank aufmachen
Jedes Zeugs mitnehmen
Und die Einwohner von dieser Hütte denken so
Hopp, ist mir egal
Da läuft irgendein Typ in Ritterrüstung
und Schild und läuft durch mein Wohnzimmer
und nimmt Zeug mit
Aber das ist egal, das juckt mich nicht
Das ist egal
Was gibt es hier?
Zu looten
Einen Arm gibt es zu looten
Knüppel
Knüppel plus zwei
Ich müsste echt mal einem Clary beibringen
mit Knüppel zu kämpfen
weil ich habe so viele
nice Knüppel schon und Streitkolben
die keiner richtig verwenden kann
Ja, in Witcher 3 war es auch so
Oh, jetzt geht ja was aufgeploppt
gerade
Wo ist was? Ach, der hinter...
Ach, hier war der hintereingang
Ich hätte mich hier einfach reinschleichen können
Ja, hätte ich das mal gewusst
Da hätten wir die wahrscheinlich alle
baschen können und gut wäre gewesen
Aber wir sind ja gut
Wir baschen keine Exenmenschen, sondern
wir gehen jetzt
zum
Das kann man bestimmt looten, das Ding
falls ich es noch nicht habe
Wir gehen jetzt zum Stammelsvater in der Geisterhütte
und baschen wir den halt
Habe ich schon gelootet
oder war gar nicht zu looten
Ach, zur Geisterhütte
Moment, da müssen wir hin
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Die haben quasi eine Hütte
mit einem Kranken drinnen
die Häuptlingshütte und die
Schamadenhütte
Mehr braucht man nicht, oder was?
Das Rest ist outdated
Ist... das ist das Kind?
Das ist das Kind, was ich retten soll
Komm mit
Kleiner Junge steht in der Mitte
Blablabla
Wat?
Das ist der Stammelsvater
Aha
Ok, das muss hier irgendwie Illusionsfake
mäßig sein
Da ist sofort das Kind frei
Keine Angst
Wertvoller als Gegenleistung
Du kannst froh sein, wenn ich dich nicht basche
Da habe ich auch gut geskillt
Erfolgreich
Erfolgreich, nice
Ich tendiere ja dazu
aber ich bin ja guter Gesinnung
Ich mache sowas ja nicht
Ich tendiere aber trotzdem dazu
Was machst du hier?
Was willst du mit dem Kind?
Was willst du vom Klapperer?
Vielleicht kommen wir
zu einer anderen Übereinkunft
Keine Angst, wir holen dich hier raus
Deine Mutter liebt dich und warte auf deine Rückkehr
Ok, ich habe anscheinend gar keine andere
Option wie den Typ
zu baschen
Ach so
Nee, nee
Ich soll irgendwie dieses komische andere
Viech an ihnen ausliefern
Was jetzt?
Eigentlich wollte ich den baschen
Jetzt sind aber so viele
Exenmenschen drinne
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Warum sollte ich hier großartig mit Exenmenschen
erst mal looten
Warum sollte ich hier groß mit Exenmenschen
verhandeln? Wir können uns einfach buffen
und alles baschen
Aced
Ich will einfach nur mal gucken
ob die was können
Und Max, du gehst mal weg
Fireball, nee da
Voll rein
Die Exenmenschen, die fressen bestimmt
nicht dadurch
Oder auch nicht
Ich finde es witzig
wie die Kampfmusik
kaputt geht
Au
Clary heilen
Zack, gebashed
Wo ist das Kind jetzt?
Wir haben den Jungen aus den Fängen
dieser bösen Geister befreit
Ach da ist er
Ich dachte der war nur verhandelt
Ok, was gibt es denn zu looten?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so wirklich
ob wir die Quest auf die Art und Weise
gelöst haben wie das gedacht ist
Aber ich habe als Baron
dieser Ländereien
ehrlich gesagt keine Lust
da mit Exenmenschen irgendwie
Geschäfte zu machen
Aber Exenmenschen ist ja auch so ein
heikes Thema für alle
verschwunden
also ein heikes Thema für alle
Verschwörungstheoretiker
Es gibt ja Leute die vermuten
dass der Leibwächter
von Obama auch ein Exenmensch
war
Verlustung plus eins sagt
Amulett der natürliche
Nuristung plus eins haben wir auch schon
Ich glaube wenn ich jetzt hier raus
gehe
Ja, tatsächlich
Such mal
Du musst da mal
auf YouTube nachsuchen
Das ist wirklich bescheuert
Also wenn ihr mal was lustiges sehen wollt
Da müsst ihr euch angucken
den
Exenmensch Bodyguard
von Obama
und ihr müsst euch angucken
Obama Shapeshifter
Also wer noch nicht genug
Verschwörungstheorien hat
Ich muss jetzt sagen
Obama Shapeshifter ist ja meine
Lieblingsverschwörungstheorie
Ich mein
Es ist ja auch eh schon geil
wenn man sich überlegt
Wie viele
Quasi in der heutigen
Zeit tatsächlich den ganzen
Krämpel klauben
Ja man weiß nicht
so genau
Ja damit hätte ich jetzt eigentlich
Rechnen können dass hier jetzt erstmal
Alles voller Exenmenschen ist draußen
Zack an
Wir haben jetzt einfach nur mal nebenbei das
Komplette Exenmenschen Dorf ausgerottet
Und das als eigentlich
Guter Charakter
Aber ich bin
Und ich will mit Exenmenschen
nicht verhandeln Ich kann es ja sogar
RPG technisch begründen
Da kommen aber ganz schön viele jetzt
Da müssen wir doch nochmal einen
Feuerball reinhauen würde ich sagen
So viel Damage macht der Feuerball letztlich
Oh Amiri kriegt übelst auf den Sack
Da hätte ich mich ein bisschen besser auf den Fight vorbereiten müssen
Drista
Drista macht Heil
Und der Max
Der Max macht Feuerdamage
Auf die Kollegen hier unten
Auf den hier, den macht der Feuerdamage
Valerie muss den da bashen
Alter Amiri kriegt aber echt auf den Sack
Die tankt auch gerade alleine
Das ist ziemlich mies
Das sollte ich eigentlich gar nicht machen
Aber
Tristan heilt
Und der hier oben ist da
Valerie tankt die
Und der Max castet noch ein paar
Feuerbälle hier rein
Komm Tristan hau einfach deinen kompletten Heel raus
Oder Magic Missle
Was haben wir sonst noch für
Haste brauchen wir ganz vergessen
Mit Haste geht gleich alles viel einfacher
Tristan du sollst heilen
Ja mit Haste wird durchgeschnitzelt
Gigabit Internet für Deutschland 2020
Das ist tatsächlich eine
Sehr gewagte Verschwörungstheorie muss ich sagen
Okay
Ich glaube wir haben das
Rein aus XP Sicht
Ziemlich gut gelöst
Wir haben quasi die komplette XP abgegriffen
Von der Quest Chain im Dorf
Und danach alles gekillt
Das ist
Denke ich ziemlich optimal
So und die Knüppel können wir alle verkaufen
Die
Meisterarbeit Knüppel können wir alle verkaufen
Jetzt haben wir sozusagen mit
Max die Quest
Ich höre da von rechts
Noch Dinger
Ist aber
Nichts meine Damen
Ja also zum Thema Internet
Ausbau finde ich auch wieder geil
Ich poste ja das immer mal
Auf Twitter diese Geschichte
Oh da ist noch was
Um daran zu erinnern was da öfters
Mal für eine Scheiße erzählt wird
Weil
Es hat ja Anfang des Jahres
Der Regierungssprecher gepostet
So nach dem Motto ja also 2018
Bis Ende 2018 50 MBit
Easy Mode überhaupt kein Ding
Alles kein Thema
Obwohl eigentlich ja
Bekannt ist das für die letzten Jahre
Auch schon jegliches Breitband Ziel
Immer verkackt haben
Und
Da hatte dann sogar noch die Telekom drauf geantwortet
Irgendwie haben sie das alle so getan
Als wäre das jetzt auf einmal so
Deswegen retweete ich das
Alle paar Monate mal wieder
Um daran zu erinnern wie
Beknackt das eigentlich ist
Weil das wird natürlich nicht erreicht
Das war aber auch schon vorher klar
Übrigens den Sack können wir auch
Heuten warum auch immer
Diesen Sack heuten kann
Man weiß nicht
Aber da sieht man dass da einfach wieder Dinge
Gehauen werden obwohl man
Weiß dass es kompletter Schwachsinn ist
Einfach so nach dem Motto
Die Leute sind da nicht damit zufrieden
Dann hauen wir doch jetzt einfach mal raus
50 MBit für jeden bis Ende 2018
Gar kein Problem easy
Kein Ding und dann irgendwie
Kurz vor Ende 2018 also jetzt
Man so Leute
Das funktioniert doch nicht
Wer hätte das gedacht
Und das beste an diesem Post war
Ja dass sie geschrieben haben
Flächendeckend quasi
50 MBit für jeden
Bis Ende 2018
Und dann haben sie noch dabei
Geschrieben aber heutzutage
Müssten wir ja schon in Gigabit denken
Wo ich mir auch
Gedacht habe also in welchem Land
Hallo
Ja
Gut dann gehen wir halt durch das Haupttor raus
Was willst du machen
Wo leben die eigentlich in ihrem Kopf
Dass man wirklich davon ausgeht
Dass man
Hallo Tür öffnen
Tür öffnen
Also sprich wo lebt man im Kopf
Dass man quasi weiß man hat es
Die letzten Jahre nicht einmal geschafft
Ein Ziel zu erreichen
Und jetzt auf einmal
Das Ziel zu erreichen
Ist Gigabit am Start
Oder wie
Wie soll das gehen
Man weiß es nicht genau
Aber ich mein man kann
So was einfach mal erzählen
Zweihändige Keule plus
Eins sagt braucht man nicht
Knüppel
Ja aber das ist wirklich lächerlich in Deutschland
Wie es gerade geschrieben hat im Chat
Total
Beknackt
Hier kann man nicht lang
Das ist der einzige das überlebt hat hier
Der Typ den ich eigentlich dem
Anführer bringen sollte
Gucken was der dazu sagt jetzt dass ich sein ganzes Dorf
Niedergemetzelt habe
Oder mag
Mich auch noch dafür dass ich sein
Komplettes Dorf gebetcht habe
Nice
Gehen
Gut die Quest ist fertig
Es bleibt jetzt soweit ich das gesehen habe
Eigentlich nur noch
Die Main Quest weiterzumachen
Ich hab jetzt nichts mehr offen
Ich hab alles erledigt
Verschwundenes Kind
Genau muss ich in die Hauptstadt
Hauptstadt mit der Mutter reden
Fertig
Und dann
Main Quest weitermachen
Alles klar machen wir
Wir können noch hier kurz vorbei gehen
Mal schauen was es da so gibt
Aber vorher Leute
Ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start
Musik
So wieder am Start
Guckt ihr eigentlich noch Let's Plays
Auf Youtube
War so ne Frage
An euch jetzt
An den Chat
Guckt noch jemand Let's Plays
Auf Youtube und wenn ja
Hier da so
Weil ich hab so den Eindruck
Dass
Let's Plays
Nicht mehr so das
Ding auf Youtube sind
Also klar ich mein
Channels wie Kronk haben immer Zuschauer
Da wirst du nicht drüber reden
Ähm
Aber
Ich hab den Eindruck
Es ist nicht mal so angesagt
Und ich glaube
Das liegt
Vor allem daran, dass viele Leute
Mittlerweile Streams gucken
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen
Ich find so nen Stream
Für nen Let's Play viel unterhaltsamer
Und viel angenehmer
Zu gucken als so nen
Statisches Let's Play auf Youtube
Musik
Also mit Statisches Let's Play
Mein ich halt weil es
Nicht interaktiv ist
Und halt auch nicht
Man halt einfach nicht so live dabei ist
Klar man kann Kommentare schreiben und sowas
Aber es ist viel lustiger
Wenn man auf Twitch und Streamen guckt
Und einen Chat dabei hat
Und irgendwie sind
Let's Plays auf Youtube finde ich nicht mehr so das Ding
Wie es noch früher gewesen ist
Da
Mammoth ist back
In the Hood
Da ist es
Mammoth ist wieder da
Musik
Ja ich mach wieder Videos sobald es neue Games gibt
Die mir Bock machen
Okay
33 Erfahrungspunkte
Das ist jetzt typische RPG Logik
Bevor wir jetzt mit dem Besitzer des Hauses reden
Laufen wir einmal durch ganze
Haus und
Plündern das
Weil das interessiert ja keinen
Zack
Weil
Rgb
RPG Logik
Rgb Logik ja war es anders
Musik
Das ganze Zutaten Cram
Ein Schleuderstab
Was macht man da mit einem Schleuderstab
Jetzt sagt nicht schleudern
Musik
Ich würde gerne die Nacht hier verbringen.
Ich will deine Waren sehen.
Okay.
Weil ich mein, Diplomatie hab ich halt viel, viel Punkte drauf.
Hier ist euer Schlüssel.
Okay, das Mammut ist noch ein bisschen debuffed.
Weil's eben einmal verreckt ist.
Also wie viel Lebenspunkte hat eigentlich mein Mammut? 81 und wie viel hat der Hund?
Ach nacht, warum hat der Hund, warum hat der Hund mehr Lebenspunkte als das Mammut?
Also, mal ganz unabhängig, wenn ihr jetzt euch überlegen müsstet, welches Pet hat wohl mehr Trefferpunkte?
Das da oder das da? Was würdet ihr denken?
Und welches Pet macht mehr Damage? Das da oder das da?
Also so, ne, normalerweise würde man aus dem Bauchhaus sagen, das hier ist DPS-Pet und das ist Tank-Pet.
Zureil von der Optik, aber nicht so in diesem Game.
Okay, gehen wir mal gucken, was es hier oben gibt, weil wir haben ja den Schlüssel aus dem Hinterzimmer geklaut.
Oh fuck, ich hätte speichern sollen, wenn ich oben bin.
Weil eine fragwürdige Designentscheidung, die die Entwickler hier von diesem Game getroffen haben, ist,
man kann Schlosserklacken nur einmal pro Held probieren.
Was heißt, ich hab nur Lindsay dabei, die das ordentlich kann und wenn Lindsay failed bei dem Schloss,
wie schwer ist denn das Schloss?
Alter, ich hab jetzt zweimal gefailed mit plus 14, weil ich eine 1 gewürfelt hab, oder was?
Oh man, so und das ist halt eine fragwürdige Entscheidung, weil letztendlich führt es eh nur dazu,
dass man reloadet und versucht die Tür zu knacken.
Alter, komm on Lindsay, rechst das doch hin.
Das ist halt total dumm, sollen sie halt sagen, okay man braucht einen festgelegten Wert für eine Tür?
Und nicht diese Ladegeschichte da.
Aber wenn wir das Haus plündern, dann plündern wir es schon richtig.
Aha, was ist da drin, Resistenzumhang plus 2, sehr nice.
Ich glaube, könnte man sogar unseren Ranger anziehen.
Wir könnten's, ich glaube, die braucht das hier gar nicht mehr.
Nee, weil die hat schon den Ring.
Rüstungsarm Schienen plus 3, die braucht das hier auch nicht, guck mal.
Die haben das alles schon, aber Rüstungsklasse 36 ist halt richtig krass, echt viel.
Massive, huge, huge Rüstungsklasse ist das.
Der kann den anziehen, the Rangers.
Massive Rüstungsklasse.
Komm Lindsay, Tür knacken, ich hab keinen Bock zu reloaden.
Haha, ooooh, sehr, sehr nice, 2000 Goldstücke.
Einfach mal das komplette Haus geplündert wird wieder.
Nice, jetzt läuft das Schlösserklackengaber.
Oh nee, reload.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine bescheuerte Entscheidung gewesen, dass man jedes Mal reloaden muss,
dass man das nochmal ausprobieren kann.
Ich will noch kurz was gucken.
Was sagt ihr eigentlich zur Mini-Playstation?
Sollte ein Baron eigentlich seine Leute beschützen und nicht bestehlen?
Ja, das ist dehnbar.
Ich beschütze die Leute, Alter Lindsay, ich beschütze die Leute und dafür kriege ich
natürlich auch was.
Moin der Apfel, komm Lindsay, Tür knacken, haha, Moment, kann ich jetzt pennen?
Ich kann die Tür knacken, um mich dann in das Bett zu legen, ja ist klar.
Jetzt looten.
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich noch nicht mal, was da drin ist, aber ich sehe es nicht ein,
dass ich mich, was brauchen wir denn, Schwierigkeitsgrad 27, Wurf 1, ernsthaft 1, ich habe eine plus
14 Aufschlösser, haha, hat funktioniert.
Ich gehe nochmal speichern, sehr schön, ah, was haben wir denn hier?
Größere Klasse 3 Verbesserung, das kann Lindsay anziehen, wo ist es denn?
Macht das sonst noch irgendwas?
Das ist alles RNG, ja das ist schon klar, dass es RNG ist, die Sache ist die, ich finde
das ist eine Mechanik, die sich nicht gut auf Computerspiele überträgt, es spricht
nichts dagegen, dass man so einen Schwellwert macht, ab wann man einen Schlösser knacken
kann, dann sollte man einfach sagen, ok, du bist über dem Schwellwert drunter, du bist
unter dem Schwellwert drunter, Pech gehabt, weil ansonsten führt das einfach nur dazu,
dass die Leute beliebig lang probieren, wenn sie eine Chance drauf haben, und es ist nervig,
deswegen sollte man es einfach nicht machen, so, wir haben jetzt eigentlich hier alles
durch, ne, dann müssen wir jetzt in die Hauptstadt und danach den Main-Quest weitermachen.
Ja, PS1, ich wollte irgendwas zur PS1 sagen, deswegen hatte ich gefragt, ich habe es aber
voll verdrängt, was ich wollte, tja, vielleicht fällt mir es wieder ein, Hauptstadt, was
wollte ich denn, was wollte ich denn mit der PS1, PS1 Classic, hm, ich weiß es nicht
mehr, ja ok, also, Cashew, das kann schon sein, das ist, oh, oh, das Ding basht bestimmt
ordentlich, ordentlich rein, Cashew, das kann schon sein, aber dann sollte man es vielleicht
als Option machen oder so, aber defaultmäßig finde ich es blöd, weil, ich könnte wetten,
dazu gibt es sogar irgendwelche Untersuchungen, dass die meisten Spieler, sobald sie eine
Chance drauf haben, dass einfach mit Reload, und Reload möglich ist, einfach so oft Reload
bis es funktioniert, das könnten wir als Option machen, man könnte sogar sagen, ich
spiele es ja auch fordernd, wenn man es da standardmäßig einschaltet, meinetwegen,
aber es ist halt überall so, oh, das Ding frisst, frisst gut, ok, Feuerbälle müssen
wir da logischerweise, oder wahrscheinlich nicht drauf schießen, waffen wir mal das
Mammut, ja, wir schießen jetzt einfach Missiles drauf, das ist super, ok, wieso hat Tristan
bei dir so viel Heal, ähm, weil ich das geskillt habe, also ich hab, kann ich dir,
warte mal, ich zeig's dir, ich hab things geskillt, paar mal, zusätzliches Fokussieren
hab ich dreimal gespeckt, und es gibt, äh, gibt zweimal zusätzlich, plus, was man nicht
vergessen darf, er hat bei mir auch, ähm, einen Armreif an, nee, nee, kein Armreif,
sondern einen Stirnreif an, der Weisheit bringt, und Weisheit ist wichtig für Clary Spells,
Spells, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die, wie gesagt, so sehr kenne ich mich im
Pathfinder Regelwerk nicht aus, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Anzahl der Ladung
auch was mit meinem Attributwert zu tun hat, wie viel Clary Spells man kriegt, anscheinend
er wirklich, oh, aber Clary kriegt, easy, ich hätt' jetzt eigentlich gedacht, es wird
viel schwieriger, und es gibt sechs Soluten, das ist ja enttäuschend, aber ich weiß, ich
glaub, Int bringt Clary's nichts, also damals eigentlich Life is Strange gespielt, nein,
hab ich nicht, gibt eh so ein paar Games, die ich noch spielen muss, wenn's danach geht,
was die letzten Jahre so rausgekommen ist, aber ich krieg' das irgendwie nicht hin,
also alles, was man noch spielen müsste zu spielen, kommt da nicht hinterher, Moment,
warum wurde dieses Dorf hier jetzt gerade frei, frei gegeben bei mir, ich mein, es ist
nicht so, dass ich's von hier sehen könnte oder so, gut, okay, aber ich geh' erstmal
in die Hauptstadt, und guck mal, was es Neues gibt, muss halt noch wenig arbeiten, hab ich
mir tatsächlich überlegt, hab ich mir tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich nicht noch einen Tag wenig
arbeiten sollte, ich bin letztens erst wieder überlegt, oh, es gibt neue Ereignisse, oh,
der hat's verkackt, seinen Auftrag, Tristan hat's gut gemacht, okay, die anderen sind
auch beschäftigt, drei Tage Straßen bauen, 54 Tage das hier, wichtige Veröffentlichung,
okay, ich muss den Thronsaal einmal, ich muss mehr Jungfrauen bashen, ein echtes Meisterwerk,
mach das einfach mal, um die Fluss Jungfrau kümmert sich Tristan, oh, in den Thronsaal
muss ich eh, Herr Sebaro, ich hab' letzten Monat, also wenn's jetzt hier eben so YouTube
Video und so geht, ich hab' letzten Monat, glaube ich, YouTube AdSense 28 Dollar bekommen,
ja, also, da kann man schon ordentlich was reißen mit, glücklicherweise hab' ich jahrelang,
der Thronsaal, jahrelang Amazon Links, Ref Links gespammt, und die bringen irgendwie egal,
ob man was macht, ob man aktiv ist, was hoch oder nix macht, die bringen immer Kohle, Amazon
Links ist eigentlich das Beste, was man machen kann, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das
übertrieben viel wäre, das steht und fällt alles damit, wie aktiv man Videos macht, und
aktuell mach' ich ja quasi nichts, eine äußerst ungewöhnliche Nachricht, ich hab' unangenehme
Nachricht, das gelesen, ja, was ist es denn, ja, stimmt, der Typ wollte ein Buch über
mich schreiben, dann, wenn er das gerne machen will, wird die jetzt bekommen, ist mir eigentlich
wurscht, so, achso, jaja, Siebauer, also, wenn's danach geht, ich hab' da eigentlich
keine Sorgen, irgendwie, so, jetzt müssen wir, jetzt mal gucken, was müssen wir jetzt
machen, eigentlich, ja, Valerie, sollen wir mal sagen, wie's hier läuft, ich könnte
auch mit Valerie flirten in dem Game, aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, hab' ich auf
irgendwelche NPC-Romance-Geschichten, kein Bock, man kann in dem Game, weil's die Leute
immer wissen wollen, wenn so was gibt, also in dem Game gibt's, glaub' ich, vier oder
fünf, ich glaube vier, NPC-Romance-Optionen, einmal Valerie gibt's, dann gibt es, Valerie
steht nur auf Männer, dann gibt es einen Halb-Org, der auf Männer und Frauen steht, also quasi
richtig Copper Pride, dann gibt's es irgendwie noch eine Halb-Elfin, die auch auf Männer
und Frauen steht, und es gibt Tristan, der glaub' ich auch auf Männer und Frauen, irgendwie
so, also in dem Game hier kann man sich komplett austoben, wie man will, wenn man denn NPC-Romances
will, aber ich bin irgendwie, bin keinem der Games großartiger Fan von irgendwie NPC-Romance,
weil die meisten Dialog-Optionen sind immer so übelst cringe, das, das wäre eigentlich
zu blöd, wer läuft da eigentlich rum, ach, die Wache, hier, ähm, tja, ja, also das hier
oben ist die, das da ist die Elfin, mit, die man romanzen kann, das hier ist der Halb-Org
und Valerie steht hier oben irgendwo rum, warum, warum ich auch immer ihr so'n Hut aufgezogen
hab, so, wir müssten anscheinend jetzt Main-Quest machen, oh, es gibt eine Zwischensequenz,
die ich jetzt komplett, äh, übersehen hätte, wenn's mich nicht automatisch hinscrollen
würde, welche Ehre euch heute zu treffen, denn sie möchte ich mir mal vorstellen, ok,
Buchhändlerin, was man als Baron nicht alles machen muss, oder, man muss sich wirklich
um jeden Scheiß kümmern, wo kommt ihr her, wie seid ihr denn sie begegnet, was hat euch
hergeführt, bleibt ihr, ich könnte noch ein paar, ähm, Helfer brauchen, für, für Aufgaben
hier in, in der Baronie, das wäre nicht schlecht, wie steht das, gibt es Nachrichten, was ist
da los, hat sich jemand über mein Land erkundigt, danke, das reicht, ja, ein nicer Dialog, weiter
Main-Quest, äh, wir können mal gucken, ob uns, ob meine Händler mittlerweile mehr haben,
äh, wartet mal, wie lange hab ich eigentlich noch Zeit für die Quest hier, 87 Tage, ja,
dann machen wir die Main-Quest vorher weiter, der alte Mann verneigt sich, blablabla, zeigt
mir, was ihr anzubieten habt, nur Crap, was sind das, Ringen des Reichhalteren, Gewähr
plus eins auf Schadenswürfe mit Bogen und einen Glücksbonus, Schadenswürfe mit Bogen
kann eindeutig unser Ranger gebrauchen, der hatte noch nichts in der Richtung, Tiergefährten
erhalten, ein Verbesserungs, oh, aha, den brauche ich, da basht mein Mammut noch mehr,
da hat mein Mammut plus zwei Stärke und plus zwei Geschick, so muss das sein, äh, unser
Ranger kriegt mehr Bogendamage, erhöht die Rettungswürfe, das dreht jetzt um eins, was
haben wir sonst hier noch, Duellhandschuhe, Entwaffnen, Stirnreif, den hab ich schon, Rüstung,
das wär was für Amiri, oder, wobei, nee, die hat nen, Halskette der Ewing hier, die
Halskette gewährt Angriffsbonus von zwei und einen Schadensbonus von plus vier gegen
Tiere und Magische Besten, das wär wirklich was für unseren Barb, und ich sollte eigentlich
auch genug Kohle haben, ja ich muss hier, ich hab hier nämlich schon massig Zeug zu
verkaufen, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack,
erstmal alles Lichtmagische verkaufen, so, schaust du eigentlich Serie, und wenn ja,
empfiehlt zu in letzter zeit habe ich wenig geguckt was fand ich muss man
überlegen was fand in die letzte serie die ich geguckt habe ich habe die
dritte staffe von preacher geguckt ich habe
habe ich denn
in letzter zeit habe ich da nicht viel muss ich sagen also was ich wirklich
ganz gut finde oder ganz gut fand moment ich muss erst mal gucken dass ich
mir das zeug leisten kann hier selber gibt es hier noch irgendwas was ich
kurzpunkt plus eins kann ich verkaufen braucht kein mensch mehr sei plus eins
kann ich verkaufen habe ich überhaupt keine klasse die das verwenden kann und wenn
ich mal eine habe und die verwenden kann ich mir das zeug kaufen weil plus eins
auch kann er das verwenden kann streit käumen habe ich ein scharfes lang
schwert brauche ich nicht habe ich bessere
das verkaufen wir bestimmt nicht kriegshammer auch nicht das auch nicht
also alle named items verkaufen nicht zweihändige käule plus eins brauche ich
nicht habe ich auch was besseres schleuter schleuderstab den behalten wir
mal weiß nicht wie viel da ist eis streitachs plus eins könnte man mal
behalten schwerer streit kolben plus eins brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht
kurzschwert plus eins bräuchte auch nicht bastan schwert plus eins brauche ich
auch nicht habe ich auch schon besseres tja jetzt
ja er ist serien stimmt also eine sache die ich echt cool fand habe ich auch
schon mal im stream gezeigt die irgendwie gar nicht so bekannt ist aber
die fand ich echt gut ist ist das hier
fand ich echt nicht übel
loki versus dokter haus das ist aber nach irgendeinem buch das heißt die story
ist in der regel schon mal kann schon mal nicht ganz so beknackt sein die
meisten buchverfilmungen haben zumindest was story anbelangt immer halbwegs hand
und fuß so also jetzt was rüsten wir aus
amiri kriegt die halskette was warum steckt das
amiri verwirrt mich
moment ist rüstungs ist rüstungs bonus was anderes als rüstungsklasse anscheinend
amiri krieg ich schon so auf die fresse die noch weniger rüstungsklasse will ich
der nicht zumuten aber wir können der den schutz umhang anziehen
dann hat sie wieder 22 okay das check ich jetzt nicht na gut dann behält
die das erstmal an unser ranger kriegt ne das krieg ich kriegt der max der max
kriegt für seinen mammut mammut dex punkte und das da kriegt unser boogie
wo ist er da hier damit der mitsch da marke
kann es sein dass das hier verpackt ist und überhaupt nichts macht seht ihr
irgendwie sich die stats verändern ich glaube kann das sein dass es verpackt
ist dieses item oder ist rüstungs bonus was anderes wie wie das hier gibt es
könnte auch das könnte schon sein ja gut dann wieso bist du mit deinem
hexenmeister so stark auf charisma gegangen weil ich ein wald hexenmeister
bin und ein wald hexenmeister hat als karstattribut charisma
normaler hexen weißheit glaube ich weißheit
und als wald hexenmeister kriegt man mit pet und ein paar andere naturspels mit
mit level ab aber das pet ist das wichtigste eigentlich so habe ich
irgendwie die möglichkeit an dieses komische ammo anzuziehen weil ein cool
wer das schon
ich muss gleich noch mal zum händler verkaufen aber das irgendwie sortieren
sortieren nach
ich glaube diese armen schienen sind verpackt ja keshi ich weiß das steht
da aber guck mal die beim amulett funktioniert guck mal beim amulett geht
bei der arm schiene geht es nicht deswegen habe ich mir das andere
amulett ja auch erst nur gekauft weil ich gedacht habe ich habe ich schon plus
drei hier von da brauche ich das nicht mehr ich würde einfach mal sagen das
ist entweder ein anderer bonus weil es hier explizit um rüstungsklasse geht um
hier und rüstungsbonus was auch immer der unterschied ist ja
achte ach bonus ist quasi was sich hier drauf auswirkt oder was
ok was auch immer da hört es bei mir mit pers feiner
kenntnissen auf dass ich das ist was unterschiedliches ist dachte ich mir
schon aber was was ist rüstungsbonus
aber ich könnte amiri den schutz ring geben
ich könnte amiri den schutz ring plus zwei geben und dann kann ich das hier
ausziehen ne das wirkt auch das wirkt zusätzlich rüstungsklasse des trägers
steigert nicht und hier ist die rüstungsklasse des nutzer steigt um 2
nicht also entweder ist die deutsche übersetzung total bescheuert und das
ergibt keinen sinn hier steht es plus zwei rüstungsklasse
steckt nicht hier steht es plus zwei rüstungsklasse steckt nicht
kann ich aber auch mit leben da hat amiri jetzt wenigstens plus 24
rüstungsklasse ok ich glaube das ist glaube ich ein bisschen das problem ich
gehe mal davon aus dass diese allen für diese ganzen drei werte dass es drei
unterschiedliche werte sind und wenn man das wahrscheinlich auf englisch lesen
würde dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen klarer
raus raus kristallisieren was wir ist lassen das erst mal so amiri braucht auf
jeden fall rüstungsklasse weil die ist immer so schnell dauern oder wird es
wenigstens schlechter getroffen so verkaufen wir noch mal die ganzen
mists den ich hier habe handeln zack
gut weiter geht's mein quest eine verdiente belohnung verschwunden
achte das verschwundene kind wir müssen noch zur mutter gehen wir müssen noch
zur mutter die natürlich wo soll sonst sein in der taverne steht wenn das die
feministen wieder mitkriegen
okay kashi und rossel ich glaube euch das ist ja auch sieht man ja auch in
game ich finde so ein bisschen unglücklich geschrieben dass das nicht
so klar wird was was ist ich meine es ist cool bei einem bei der pen and paper
variante wenn du dann fast ein item hast und dann kannst du dann hast du so einen
schönen flavor text quasi so dazu bei in games fände ich halt schön wenn man
einfach ein paar item statistiken hinschreibt weißt du hier tabelle plus
plus plus plus steckt nicht kommt da einfach ein bisschen klarer raus wie
wie was zusammen funktioniert sauber steht in die mutter hier um da
quest beendet man kriegt schon wieder level ab und es dauert noch es wird viel
in dem spiel erklärt tatsächlich wobei ich das eigentlich eigentlich ganz cool
finde das ist also nein das stimmt nicht ich finde ich cool dass vieles nicht
erklärt wird ich finde es cool dass es relativ komplex ist das war wohl in der
taverne das war und läuft mir überall nach das war mutter nix ich finde cool
dass es komplex ist und auch dass die vorlage wohl ganz gut übernimmt das
das finde ich schon nice man hätte manche sachen doch schon ein bisschen
besser an den pc spiel anpassen können aber ich bin ich echt zufrieden mit dem
game das ist eines der besten classic rpts die so letzten jahren gegeben hat
was ich halt richtig geil finde ist dass man so viele freiheiten hat man kann
eigentlich machen was man will ok jetzt gehen wir mein quest machen
so unsere main quest sagt nämlich ich soll die nünfe in ihren grünen gemächern
treffen tja da wohl dann gleich sehen wir
was stand da noch berichter baron würde ich mich mit unsichtbarkeit
tränken und anderen mitteln eindecken um ärger zu vermeiden ok dann gehe ich mal
nicht davon aus dass gleich mit der nünfe hier übelst abgehen wird sondern
dass ich versucht werde zu bashen gucken wir versucht wird mich zu killen
gucken ob ich unsichtbarkeit tränken dabei habe müsste ich eigentlich haben
was zum teufel ist die unsichtbarkeit tränken verschwinden es könnte sogar
sein dass ich scrolls hab mit verschwinden und vielleicht habe ich auch
unsichtbarkeit habe ich nicht als spell das wäre jetzt natürlich auch zu schön
gewesen was was mit schleichen das kann gut sein dass gleich geschlichen wird
und dafür brauche ich auf jeden fall unsichtbarkeit tränken wenn ich
schleichen soll weil moment mein hält kann nicht schleichen
der ist unglaublich schlecht im schleichen so mein quest ja wir nehmen
altbekannte truppe mit
den zwergen clary wollte ich auch mal speck ausrüsten weil ich spiele ja
selbst zwergen clary wenn wir denn spielen allerdings 5 e
gibt's denn für neue sachen
wobei ich mit meinem zwergen clary teil war so richtig als hielbott vorkommen
im schloss wartet was auf mir das habe ich doch schon gelesen
projekte forschung ich habe keine erforschen kann
du hast vergessen dass du allein dahin soll sein das habe ich nicht vergessen
aber ich kann einfach am gebietseingang meine gruppe ändern wenn ich auf der
weltkarte bin
deswegen nehme ich die leute mal mit weil es können immer noch zufallskämpfer
auf den weg dahin kommen und da habe ich keinen bock alleine
ich glaube ohne ohne ohne rasten schaffe ich nicht keine ration verwenden ich kann
jagen wir wollen auch nichts spezielles kochen
eine sache die mir bei dem spiel auch bisschen auf den keks geht ist dass man
in ticken zu viele ladezeiten hat sowohl sowohl beim map wechseln beim hier
beim in zufallskämpfe gehen überall du hast dem tron wenn du in den tron
sahn tron sahen willst um dein königreich zu verwalten brauchst du
irgendwie zwei ladezeiten und zwei ladezeiten zurück und so das ist
ein bisschen blöd was das eine hydra tja die frage kann das ding was oder kann
das ding nix amiri macht das jetzt bar bridge sonst brauchen wir nix
kombat song können wir noch anmachen haben wir genug kann nix weil überhaupt
nichts und das ist schon schwierig als
schwierigkeitsgrad also wie man sich da beschweren kann dass das gelb zu schwer
ist ich weiß nicht es wäre die erste hydra die nix kann das ist aber was
hier hast du es zuerst gesehen die erste heitschau die nix kann die wurde mal so
was von geschreckt gerade
ein kinder gibt es in dem geld ich glaube ich bin auch ein bisschen zu zu
overleveled für akt 2 wenn ich bin schon level acht ich habe halt alles an quest
gemacht bevor ich die main quest gemacht habe und ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
diese encounter quasi auf dem weg jetzt zur so mein quest sogar gescriptet sind
für solo hält für welche ihre gruppe halt nicht mitnehmen weil das da steht
man soll alleine gehen ich gehe das aber trotzdem mit meiner gruppe rein weil ich
habe jetzt eigentlich gar nicht vor die nymphen zu bängen sondern gucken was da
so abgeht
ich gehe da erst mal mit der gruppe reingucken und sollte sollte es halt
gar nicht gehen dann lasse ich meine gruppe am eingang stehen
und geht dann alleine hin das ist wie ein schneesturm nur heiß
kein spaß mit der nymphen näher nachdem in der quest beschreibung drinne steht
ich soll unsichtbarkeit strengen mitnehmen gehe ich mal nicht davon aus
dass es dazu kommen wird ich gehe das davon aus dass die nymphen mich
bashen will spielst du noch overwatch nein aktuell nicht und ich glaube auch
in nächster zeit nicht aber kann das sein dass irgendwie ein host oder so
übersehen habe freund
auch nice mein mammoth läuft da oben drauf
wieso nicht also dann lasse ich mich am ende fakt jeden jeden stream einmal
darüber aus was mit overwatch ist also zum einen mal weil ich finde dass das
ranking system immer noch unter aller sau ist ich finde es nicht gut wie
blizzard die competitive szene handelt außer der overwatch league und die
overwatch league ist ja nur unbestreitbar relativ erfolgreich aber
das das war halt auch so ein ding das war schon zu groß um zu fehlen im
endeffekt also egal wie man da reinstecken muss also ich soll mich mal
angucken wie das mit tier 2 und nachwuchsgeschichten aus in overwatch
auch nichts ja aber zum zum spiel selbst würde ich sagen der rank modus
gefällt mir immer noch nicht ich finde die spielmodi sowas wie 2cp ist immer
noch eklig die helden fokussieren sich teilweise immer noch nicht so sehr wie
ich mir das wünschen würde auf eben mecanics sondern auf timing timing
gimmicks und ja der glück kann man nicht wirklich sagen
weiß nicht wie man wie soll man das beschreiben in overwatch es hat
mal so so hell wie brigitte zum beispiel oder wie reinhard die sind jetzt ja
beide nicht die wahnsinns mechanik mäßig also du musst jetzt da nicht das gott
aim haben oder du brauchst dafür eigentlich nur den glück im matchmaking
dass das gut funktioniert mit reinhard und halt timing und du musst halt den
gegnerischen reinhard planen so es ist schwierig zu erklären irgendwie hat man
das zeug also es kann mir halt keiner sagen dass man beispielsweise für
mercy so viel skill bräuchte wie in sagen wir mal cs oder sowas ich will
jetzt nicht sagen dass kann man hier rum klettern
kommt man da überhaupt hin wenn man hier lang klettert
completed ja genau dass josen er sagt dass das so sehe ich das auch also helden
die kein skill brauchen dass das trifft im endeffekt weil es ist nicht so dass
wir für mercy oder für reinhard also mercy ist für mich das negativ bei
ich bin schlechthin dass man dafür nix so gar nichts können muss trifft es nicht
aber es ist halt nichts was wie es sein sollte aus meiner sicht halt also ich
finde es sollte ein gewisses outplay potential da sein bei den meisten helden
einfach wenn man sie gut beherrscht und das ist halt bei vielen sachen nicht so
bei vielen helden ist halt im prinzip egal wie gut du spielst weil es relativ
schnell vom level her vorbei ist wo du halt was besser reißen kannst als der
gegner und es hängt einfach nur noch komplett davon ab wie es video im
matchmaking ich muss doch alleine rein video matchmaking zusammen gewürfelt
wirst und dann hat du hast halt auch so krassen unterschied was ich halt auch
übelst übelst fail finde dass du dass du so ein so ein so ein riesen differenz
hast den aufwärts also du hast beispielsweise leute die gente denn immer
mal genji weil das josen grad am start ist ja oder nehmen wir tracer oder zum
teil noch irgendwas hast du noch irgendwie die sombra zum teil ja auch
noch oder was hinten was hinten noch so die man so zum treffen dass es soll ja
dass du hast also was wie tracer zum beispiel oder genji das sind halt helden
die schwierig zu spielen sind die auch hohen impact haben und du hast dann
sowas dann gepaart mit mercy also du hast auf der einen seite so den so den one
button hieltscher der teilweise über lange strecken in overwatch komplett
unverzichtbar ist du hast sowas hier wie brigitte die dich nachkampf stand
einfach mal so mit einer taste und dazu hast du dann quasi sowas wie
highskill tracer das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen und das ist das was mir
auch so ein bisschen gepaart mit dem matchmaking dass du überhaupt nichts mit
dem zu tun hat wie overwatch eigentlich gespielt werden sollte nämlich im team
gefällt mir einfach nicht ich hab ja ehrlich gesagt blizzard zugetraut das zu
verbessern aber irgendwie tut es dann deswegen warum dauern das wechsel meiner
gruppe drei tage kann ich nicht einfach sagen
jungs hier valerie amiri lindsey bleibt mal kurz stehen ich gehe jetzt kurz
kurz die nymphen bangen und kommen wieder zurück das geht nicht nein ich
muss die gruppe wechseln drei tage lang btf
so wir haben es drei tage gewartet so muss es sein aber mein mammut kommt mit
oder mein mammut darf bestimmt mit
ja nice mein mammut ist dabei so so mag ich das
so wir speichern jetzt erstmal hier wer weiß was da jetzt gleich kommt vor der
main quest kann man immer mal speichern
ich lasse mein mammut mal vorlaufen falls er fallen sind oder so
ich hab nicht mal reingehen sollen
okay
wir laden noch mal neu und gehen erst mal wir gehen wir gehen noch mal rein in
die festung erst mal gucken was da drinne ist bevor ich damit mein mein
bevor ich da mit meinem held rumstelze was ist denn deiner meinung nach der
größte op hero 1 und 1 brigitte also von so von skill zu passion ist brigitte
brigittar heißt sie ja glaube ich
das auch der dümmste hält überhaupt
drücke knopf für instant dann ach so ach meinst du meinst du 1 und 1 hat du
meinst diesen 1 und 1 modus boar habe ich nie gespielt
ich vermute mal sowas wie rotok ist übelst geil weil er sich heilen kann in
diesem 1 und 1 modus ich rate jetzt einfach mal da habe ich nie gespielt
also alles mit sehr viel dürfte da wahrscheinlich übertrieben geil sein
also sowas wie soldier oder oder halt eben rotok rotok vor allem auch noch
wegen dem burst potenzial wobei ich habe gelesen rotok wurde genervt der
killt jetzt nichts mehr im endeffekt der beste hält in der offensive tracer würde
ich sagen beste hält in der offensive wenn man es nicht gerade goats oder
sowas spielt würde ich sagen tracer tracer und genji aus dem grund weil man
da sehr viel reißen kann durch gutes spiel
auch ich glaube das kann ich auch nicht entschärfen oder gut leute ich hätte
hier nicht mit meinem team wieder reingehen müssen da gibt es nämlich
nichts drin dann machen wir jetzt die main quest mit
der numfung mal gucken was da so abgeht
am besten finde ich das torp rieberg was haben sie denn reworked habe ich nicht
geguckt muss ich wusste gar wie gesagt ich habe mich ewig nicht mal so
wirklich mit overwatch beschäftigt seitdem ich kein interesse mehr habe das
selbst irgendwie zu spielen was haben sie reworked so nümpfe was geht
wo ist die numfung in den gemütchen der numf ist niemand vielleicht zeigt sie
sich wenn der baron sowie vereinbart alleine betritt ja wo ist die numfung
muss ich vielleicht mein mammut auch noch wegschicken
ach nee die kommt bestimmt wenn ich den baum untersuche sonst wäre nicht umsonst
der lupe am baum mammut komm runter
level 2 tritt die fort kein level 3 tritt mehr ist das schon live der rieberg
weil ich habe vorhin da fragen geguckt und da haben wir noch torp mit hammer
angesagt
tritt kann er werfen
blizzard please komm an bra
okay nümpfe mein mammut hat es jetzt ausgelöst
auch gut wo wer hatte das gedacht ich wurde reingelegt
damit hätte man ja gar nicht rechnen können
voice acting wir haben voice acting was leider viel zu wenige dialogue in dem
spiel haben
ich habe euch geholfen es liegt keine ehre in einem angriff auf mich genau
ehrenlose nümpfe so sehe ich das auch
die
Aber was ist eine Baronin ohne ihren Baron?
So muss es sein.
Die verlassenen Lande bleiben niemanden, sterben oder rennen.
Es gibt nichts, was man verändern kann.
So, ich muss weiter oben stehen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, hat sich meine Quest gerade auf grün geschaltet?
Okay, da oben passiert mir nichts. Mein Mammut geht auch mal hier hoch.
So, und mein Mammut redet mit der Nymph wieder.
Oh, es attackiert nicht direkt. Mammut, drauf! Bam!
Die können ja gar nichts! Die können ja gar nichts, die Viecher, weil jetzt alle gebasht.
Was haben wir hier unten? Hier unten war doch auch irgendwas.
Ich stell's mich da mal kurz hin. Gucken, was da unten war.
Übrigens, in dem Game kann man keine Kamera... Oh, ein Bär. Kann man keine Kamera drehen, weil die Hintergründe statisch sind.
Ein Eulenbär. Das waren die Dinge, wo wir vorher mit der kompletten Party gegen drei Gegner Probleme hatten.
Den lass ich mal in Ruhe.
Fortnite Beste. Spielst du Fortnite, Josen? Aha. Was sagst du zu Blackout?
So, machen wir das Fisch hier nochmal kaputt. Gucken, ob das ein bisschen mehr kann.
Die haben so viele Zauber. Das ist kompletter Easy-Mode hier.
Hab ich grad meinen Mammut gebasht.
Wie viel Leben hat mein Mammut noch? 55. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Nymphe sich das gedacht hat, aber so einfach wird Baron Max nicht gebasht.
Heuten. Die Gruppe leitet unter schwerer Belastung.
Ist das so?
Jetzt läuft er nicht mehr, der Max. Der Max muss irgendwas ablegen.
Irgendeine Rüstung, die ich nimmer brauche. Irgendwas Schweres. Kann ich ja nachher wieder aufsammeln. Aber die Lederrüstung ablegen.
Ah, ich hab grad genug. So, gucken wir mal, ob wir den Bär noch gebasht kriegen. Das machen wir jetzt aber anders. Wir planten den Bär.
Nice, der Bär ist geplendet. Jetzt schicken wir das Mammut auf den Bär. Dann sprayen wir noch den Bär an.
So, jetzt ist er angesprayt. Jetzt wird er oben genugt, der Bär. Der Bär ist übrigens geplendet.
Ich muss nochmal laden. Das hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Was ist denn der beste Held, um Hard zu bashen? Was spielst du am liebsten? Support, DPS, Off-Tank, Tank? Was ist deine Lieblingsrolle?
Also den pauschalen Held zum am besten Baschen kann man jetzt so nicht sagen, vor allem wenn man neu in dem Game ist.
Mein Mammut hat immer noch einen Debuff drauf und man sieht ja nicht welchen Debuff. Das ist natürlich ziemlich kacke. Irgendeinen Debuff hat mein Mammut noch drauf.
Also ich meine, ich kann den Bär plinden lassen. Ich meine, da kann er doch eigentlich gar nichts mehr treffen. Großartig.
Fuck. Sag mal, warum macht der so einen Damage?
Fuck. Der hat übertriebenes Damage. Das ist der OP Bär. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass ich überhaupt nicht lang muss, sondern hier oben.
Ich meine, wir sind ja vorhin hier oben lang gelaufen. Da hat man ja gesehen, man kann hier neben runter irgendwo. Das probieren wir mal.
Ich probiere den Bär noch einmal zu bashen, ob das funktioniert. Ich habe leider nicht so viele Self-Buffs, weil ich dafür meinen Bade habe eigentlich.
Das wäre natürlich nice, weil das funktioniert. Oh, ich habe eine Idee. Ich habe doch den Teleport-Zauber. Ich habe doch den Teleport-Zauber.
Ja, nice. Ich teleportiere mich einfach weg. Natürlich wirkt der like that. Du musst einfach drauf schießen.
Ich hätte Haze zuerst casten müssen auch mal. Sag mal, the fuck? Scheiß Bär. OP Bär. Ich teleportiere den Bär jetzt einfach weg.
Kann ich den Bär teleportieren? So war das nicht gedacht. Ich wollte mich nicht in das Face vom Bär teleportieren, sondern ich wollte den Bär teleportieren.
Fail.
Ich bin bereit für diesen Kackbär bashen.
Wir rennen jetzt erstmal weg vor dem Viech.
Mein Mammut will da unbedingt hinrennen.
Vergiss es. Der Bär ist nicht zu bashen.
Kannst du nicht noch was summonen? Nein, ich habe nichts zum beschwören. Das ist meine Klasse nicht für gedacht.
Oh, da oben stellst du was. Ich glaube, ich muss hier oben lang. Ich vermute mal, wir haben uns das Gebiet ja vorne angeguckt.
Ich denke einfach mal, dass ich hier oben lang muss und dann hier runter muss. Das geht ja.
Die Gegner hier oben sind bestimmt einfacher zu bashen. Wahrscheinlich soll ich den Bär gar nicht bashen.
Oh, da oben kommt noch mehr. Max, caste!
Ich dachte, es rennt jetzt weg, wenn ich da 4 draufcaste.
Piss dich!
OKS! Mammut OP!
Was denkst du, wie wird sich der Battlefield 5 Ben Royale Modus gegen Black ausschlagen? Gar nicht!
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der Battlefield 5 Ben Royale Modus der übelste Reihenfall wird, weil das Ding in der Niche mit Release erscheint.
Es hat auf jeden Fall richtig viel Potenzial, einfach weil Battle Royale angesagt ist und Battlefield ein gutes Game ist im Kern immer.
Aber ich glaube, das werden sie so verkacken wie in Kersh.
Alter, wie es langschleicht.
Informatik studieren mit einer 4 in Matterport, warum denn nicht? In due time.
Aber was war die Antwort? Wer hat was geschrieben?
Weil, ich kann nur sagen, oder auch Mathe studieren oder sowas.
Oder auch, weil ich von Leuten höre, die Mathe studieren.
Das, was man in der Schule gemacht hat, ist nicht wirklich relevant. Das macht man im ersten halben Jahr oder so, oder noch mal, oder erst ein paar Wochen.
Das ist aber kein Mammut, richtig, das ist ein Mastodon.
Wo ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wusste, dass es da unten steht.
Rotkäppchen, geh weg. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Hypermonker SR, das war knapp.
Kann man den Bär von hier oben, von hier oben bashen?
Aha, ein Mastodon kann vor allem in Nordamerika von ist kleiner als ein Mammut.
Okay, aber irgendwie geht mir Mammut einfacher von den Lippen als ein Mastodon.
Wo rennst du hin?
Max, wo rennst du hin?
Häh? Egal. Ich weiß nicht, wohin er rennt, wir hüpfen jetzt hier runter. Wir hüpfen jetzt hier runter und gehen aus dem Gebiet raus.
Dann holen wir unsere Party und bashen diesen kack Bär weg.
Der Bär wird destroyed.
Ich hab kaum Beweglichkeit, ne?
Schön auf die Fresse geflogen erst mal.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch kein Wunder, ne, wenn man sich immer meine Attributen und Beweglichkeiten minus eins sagt.
Was hab ich denn gewürfelt?
Na immerhin, wenn ich dann keine 17 geworfen hätte, wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht runtergekommen.
Alter, nix wie weg hier.
So, raus hier, weg.
Die Nympha hat mich gebated.
So, und jetzt Leute, jetzt wird Party eingepackt, sag ich euch. Und dann werden die so weggeklatscht, dieser komische Bär.
Party, so, komm her. Valerie rein, Lindsay rein, Tristan rein, Amiri rein, Lindsay rein, Tristan rein, Ranger rein.
Wie heißt der eigentlich nochmal?
Ich hab mich die Namen von allen aus noch vom Ranger gemerkt, irgendwie.
Erst mal speichern, campen, wir campen ne Runde.
Wir campen ne Runde, hoffen, dass das Essen funktioniert.
Haha, jetzt haben wir Essen Bonus und er wird gebashed.
Ich hab kaum, ja egal.
Also mit vollem Team werden wir diesen komischen Bär jetzt noch erstmal wegkriegen, oder?
Face, Bär, der Bär, Bär mit weggeklatscht.
Was ist das?
Ok, erstmal meine ganzen Stoffis weg.
Ok, es war nie gedacht hier rauszugehen, weil hier wäre der Ausgang gewesen, das heißt selbst wenn ich den Bär gebashed hätte, wäre ich hier nie alleine dran vorbei gekommen, nie.
Valerie ist drauf, Amiri ist auch drauf.
Gut, die mit versammelter Mannschaft kriegen wir die wahrscheinlich weg.
Haste, Haste auf die Tanks.
Schreckt.
So, als nächstes kommt der Bär, der Bär kommt noch mit laufendem Haste, wird er gebashed jetzt, jetzt kriegt er aufs Maul der Bär.
Man, also die Kamera ist schon ein bisschen beknackt, guckt euch das mal an.
Kamera, please.
Aha.
Was macht man eigentlich wenn man jetzt kein Widescreen, also kein Monitor hat, der eine Auflösung, eine hohe Auflösung hat, dann wird das hier mit anklicken nichts.
So.
Weggeklatscht Hamasa.
Was lernen wir da raus?
Man versucht keine Nümpfel alleine.
So siehts aus.
Zwar, ich mein, allein schon wie die Quest geschrieben war, war klar das, dass da jetzt irgendwie Hinterhallen angesagt ist.
Übrigens, witzigerweise in der Quest Beschreibung stand ja man soll unbedingt Unsichtbarkeitsdränke mitnehmen.
Ich hab mein Mammut dabei, brauch kein Unsichtbarkeitsdrank.
That is not far.
Wo geht denn die Mainquest jetzt weiter?
Ich hab keine Quests mehr.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt noch mal kurz in den Tempel rein, ob das da jetzt ein bisschen anders aussieht drinne.
Ob man da jetzt was machen kann.
Schon 17.30 Uhr, ich hab Hunger.
Abtime.
Wie lang bin ich denn online? 3 Stunden 26 Minuten.
So, schicken wir mal das Mammut vor.
What?
Ich bin, ey Alter, ich steh am Arsch der Welt, ey.
WTF?
Was ist das?
Da reicht 0.3D nicht, da brauchen wir 0.4D.
She baited.
WTF?
Vor allem Level up zu minus 3, das ist übertrieben, minus 5, das ist übertrieben, krass.
Verschlossen.
Hab ich da irgendwie nen Schlüssel drinne gefunden?
Okay, das bringt überhaupt 0 hier rein zu gehen, das bringt gar nichts.
Komplett she baited.
Gut, dann gehen wir jetzt hier raus und gehen in die Hauptstadt.
Weil ich denk mal, dass es da mit der Quest weiter geht, ich hab nix mehr.
Das hier sind die Verwaltungsquests, die haben mit der normalen Story nichts zu tun.
Also ne, diese Quest, die ich in der Hauptstadt machen kann mit meinen Untertanen da, das hat mit der Mainquest nichts zu tun.
Übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit müssen wir mal sagen, das Spiel sieht echt gut aus.
Es hat schöne Zaubereffekte, schöne Beleuchtung, es ist ein schönes Wettersystem.
Also das Spiel sieht wirklich hübsch aus.
Ist übrigens ein Unity-Game, weil er gerne auf Unity rumgeflamt wird.
Was gibt's denn hier?
Wir können jetzt einfach mal weiter gehen und hier gucken, was es da gibt.
Weil es gibt hier auch nirgendswo neue Quests, es gibt gar nichts.
Oder wir sollen echt da hin.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal rüber.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal hier weiter und gucken uns das an.
Aber vorher campen wir noch ne Runde.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass beim neuen iPhone das Laden bei manchen Geräten nicht funktioniert?
Nö.
Aber ich mein, wenn schon das Laden nicht funktioniert, also quasi eines der basicsten Sachen...
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Kackwort? Also eines der grundlegendsten Sachen an einem Smartphone.
Ich kann hier nicht direkt hinlaufen. Warum nicht?
Das ist schon schwach. Also dass das Laden bei einem Handy nicht funktioniert, ist schon...
Ja, biegt sich dann wenigstens.
Das hat ja schon Tradition.
Okay, mit dem Bugi hier oben müssen wir beschäftigen.
Das darf der Hund machen.
Oh, da drüben sind auch welche. Dann darf das mein Mammut machen.
Dann darf der Mammut drübertrampeln. Jetzt Charged er. Guckt's euch an.
Der Charged Mammut. Achtung.
Oh, die werden geschnitzelt. Die wurden geschnitzelt. Schreckt. Massive schreckt.
Übrigens, man kann, bevor man ein Gebiet verlässt, auch looten. Deswegen muss man nicht zu den Gegnern hin rennen.
Guck, da kann man alles looten.
Ja, also was Apple da so macht, ich kann's ehrlich gesagt auch nur zum Teil nachvollziehen, warum man sich ein neues iPhone kauft.
Ich hab selbst ein iPhone. Und wenn's um Tablets geht, muss ich sagen, kommt Android noch nicht mal close an iOS.
Ich hab... Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle. Ich hab hier mittlerweile, ich glaub, fünf Tablets.
Ein Nvidia Shield, so ein IBM Ding, ein Asus Android Ding, ein iPad und ein TK7 und noch ein Shield.
So, eigentlich sechs Tablets. WTF. Warum eigentlich, Max? Ich weiß es selbst nicht.
Und ich muss sagen, im Tablet-Bereich not even close. iOS beste.
Im Smartphone-Bereich, muss ich sagen, würde ich der Sache prinzipiell auch zustimmen.
Ach ja, übrigens bei Tablets, sobald man was basteln will, was automatisieren will oder ein bisschen was Technisches machen will, da ist umgedreht.
Not even close für iOS. Da ist Android eindeutig das Beste.
Allerdings, die Preispolitik, was Smartphones angeht, von Apple, ist mittlerweile komplett jenseits der Vorstellungskraft von vor ein paar Jahren.
Plus, dass sie so ganz merkwürdige Design-Anscheidungen treffen wie kein Kopfhörerausgang mehr.
Oder wenn man sich bei den neuen MacBooks diese komische LED-Leiste oben anguckt, die sie anstatt von Funktionstasten reingemacht haben und sowas.
Da habe ich oftmals das Gefühl, die stehen sich selbst im Weg und machen es quasi durch ihren Designwahn, es quasi möglichst innovativ designen zu wollen, schlechter benutzbar.
Und vom Preis muss man gar nicht reden. Ich sehe es nicht ein.
Ein Drittel halbes bei manchen Leuten ein ganzes Monatsgehalt für ein Highend-Smartphone auszugeben. Ganz ehrlich, das sehe ich nicht ein.
Hallo, ich will eigentlich dahin. Ich will zum Sonnenbuckel.
Windows Phone ist tot, sagt sogar Microsoft. Windows Phone ist hinüber.
Windows Phone ist hinüber. Geschichte vorbei, Matsch.
Ich dachte erstens, es sind Drache. Oh, da kommen noch mehr.
Du gehst dahin, du gehst dahin, du machst Bardsong. Amiri, du machst Rage, du bist immerhin ein Barb.
Und der Clary macht mal eine Bless.
Sag mal, hat Amiri gerade Levelabzug gekriegt, kann das sein?
Na gut, man muss einfach rasten, dann geht das wieder weg.
Oh, die Dinger machen Damage. Oh, die Dinger machen krass Damage.
Ich glaube, in dieses Gebiet sollte ich noch nicht. Kann das sein?
Alter, okay, so viel Damage machen die gar nicht. Ich hätte vielleicht zaubern sollen.
Okay, das nächste Mal mache ich das anders. Falls ich jetzt verrecke, machen wir das anders.
Wenn man die Magiedamage nehmen, die nehme ich ordentlich, wie es aussieht.
Ja, ich sag mal, Moment, Moment, habe ich Gift? Ach, die hat Gift.
Ah, Clary, wo bist du? Clary? Ah.
So, jetzt müssen wir warten, bis das Gift abgelaufen ist. Und dann müssen wir nochmal rasten.
Und dann müssen wir nochmal rasten.
Und dann müssen wir irgendwann mal Mammut heilen wieder.
iPhone 6S, ich habe auch ein iPhone 6S. Da müssen wir gerade dabei sein, weil ich es nicht eingesehen habe, die letzten Jahre über, auch was selbst zu kaufen, ein neueres.
Dann würde ich sagen, campen wir mal eine Runde.
Der Voice Actor von Tristan, der spricht schon so erhaben immer.
Sind wir gehealt? Wir sind gehealt.
Okay, Amiri muss noch, muss noch eine Runde, eine Runde ausruhen.
Ich will einfach nur ruhen, ich brauch keine Story Einlagen gerade.
Immer noch nicht. Ja, egal, das können wir in der Hauptstadt wieder heilen.
Ich frage mich vielmehr, was für einen Debuff mein Mammut hat. Und der hat auch übelste Debuffs.
Die Pets müssen wir dann mal, mal heilen lassen in der Hauptstadt, würde ich sagen.
Es wäre halt schön, wenn man bei den Pets sehen würde, was sie für Debuffs drauf haben. Weil ich meine, bei meinen Charakteren sehe ich es ja.
Aber bei den Pets sehe ich es halt nicht. Minus zwei andere.
Keine Ahnung, man weiß es nicht.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Level Up aus?
Ach, das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Jetzt darf ich da rein.
Nachdem das quasi Highlighted wurde bei der Main-Quest, vielleicht geht es ja da weiter.
Ansonsten, wenn es da jetzt nicht weiter geht mit der Main-Quest, dann gehen wir zurück in, was ist das?
What the fuck?
Ah, gehen wir mal mit dem Pferd.
Der Pferd ist auch nicht allzu groß.
Wagen.
Ein Händler ruft um Hilfe. Moment, wir müssen erstmal Loot checken.
Ach, komme ich zu Hilfe. Erstmal Loot checken.
Okay, ist nichts.
Okay Händler, was gibt es?
Ein beleibter Mann mittleren Alters.
Jetzt fühle ich mich aber offended.
Wer seid ihr?
Was ist hier passiert?
Was haben wir zur Auswahl?
Haltet durch, ich helfe euch. Wir sind ja gut.
Atletik haben wir Amiri am Start. Die kann diesen Fail eigentlich kaum...
Ja, neutral gut. Amiri, du machst das.
Wenn wir eine 0 oder eine 1 würfeln, verkacken wir es. Aber eigentlich, statistisch gesehen, können wir es nicht verkacken.
Amiri hat runtergeholt.
Erzählt mir von euch. Was genau, das habe ich doch schon alles gefragt.
Moin Gimpling.
Wie nannten sie diesen Turm gleich nochmal?
Ich habe euch geholfen, wo ist meine Belohnung? Wo finde ich das Fehlwesen, das euch das angetan hat?
Oh, ist das das Pferd oder was?
Oh, was ist das? Das sieht aus, als muss man das Bashen. Oh, 2 Stück.
3 Stück.
Scheint mir gefährlich zu sein.
Erst mal drehen wir uns um. So, danach.
Amiri macht Rage an. Amiri macht Defensivkämpfen aus. Die kann ruhig ein bisschen Damage machen.
Der Hund geht da drauf, weil irgendwo braucht man ein bisschen was.
Valerie kann das hier tanken.
Und der Max, der castet und macht kaputt.
Ja, Amiri, du kannst hier mit draufhauen.
Tristan hat Feuerdamage, das ist bestimmt ganz gut dafür.
Okay.
Ach, die können nix.
Geht schreckt.
Easy, easy clap. Easiest clap.
Eine winzige Frau mit dunklem Haar und einer blassen...
Story.
Hallo, der Chef HB.
Der Chief HB.
Blablabla, warum?
Einschüchtern, 5 und 3.
Diesen Check werden wir wahrscheinlich verlieren.
Ich meine, ich hab einschüchtern plus 19.
Na, wobei.
Wir müssten halt 16.
Wir müssten halt 16 würfeln, was relativ unwahrscheinlich ist.
Ich probiers mal.
Ah, fuck.
Oh, so viel zu Dialogoptionen.
Das war glaub ich keine so gute Idee, diesen Check jetzt zu fällen.
Ich brauch einen Tank, ich brauch einen Tank.
Tank, Valerie.
Alter, ich brauch irgendwas, der meine Stoffis hier verteidigt.
Tristan, zaubert mal Segen.
Oh, fuck.
Max, weg.
Scheiße, das sind zu viele.
Max, wo rennst du hin?
Weg, Tristan, weg.
Scheiße.
Ah, das wird nix.
Wir haben ja wirklich von allen Seiten das Lame.
Okay, Valerie, du kannst uns am Ranger helfen.
Der Clary kann mal heilen, ne Runde.
58 hat er jetzt, krass.
58 Channels, wo kommt denn das her?
Es wird ja immer mehr.
58?
Warum hat er auf einmal 58 Channels?
Ist das verbackt oder was? Vorhin hatte er noch 38 oder so.
Ich meine, ich will nix sagen, das ist schon in Ordnung.
58 mal Channeln?
Das kann nicht stimmen, oder?
Vielleicht weil er inspiriert ist durch den Bardsong.
Fuck, der Ranger ist down.
Sonst hätte ich es geschafft.
Ich glaube, das geht in die Hose.
Ich hätte die direkt auf den drauf schicken sollen.
Das Mammut geht ab, Alter.
Das Beschworene killen wir nicht, wir killen den Beschwörer, das ist viel besser.
Amiri, kill den Beschwörer.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch eine Schriftrolle für Totenbeleben dabei.
Sobald es Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Wartet mal kurz.
Ich hoffe, ich habe noch die Schriftrolle zum Wiederbeleben dabei.
Kann mein Clary auf Range irgendwas machen außer Feuerball?
Nice, die kriegt die Frist Damage.
Und Amiri wäscht die jetzt weg.
Rippenarmut.
Lindsay, du wolltest Bardsong spielen, warum machst du das nicht?
Da geht er down.
Okay, ich hoffe, ich habe noch eine Wiederbelebungsrolle dabei, weil sonst ist schlecht.
Sonst muss ich den Scheiß noch mal machen.
Sieht nicht so aus, oder?
Doch, nice.
Ich speichere mal, weil nicht, dass mein Clary das jetzt verkackt.
Da ist er wieder.
Oh, Looten.
Wieder Rüstung, da da, sonst was, nächster.
So, ähm, Looten.
Wo ist der Zwerg eigentlich hin?
Da ist er.
Rippenarmut, schon wieder.
Hallo, Looten?
Also wirklich, was dabei hat die jetzt nicht zum Looten?
Okay, habe ich eh was vergessen zu Looten?
Nicht wirklich, das hat aber dick XP gegeben, das Ganze.
Ja, das Ding hat dick XP gegeben.
Massive, huge XP boost, huge.
Das heilt ja mal gar nichts.
Ich kann einfach meine 56 Channels verwenden.
Das ist doch ein Bug, oder?
Warum habe ich 56 Channels?
Das stimmt doch nicht.
56, vorher hatte ich 30 oder so.
Wie gesagt, ich will mich da nicht beschweren, aber das ist schon ganz schön viel.
Wenn mir der Händler nicht was anbieten zum Handeln.
Mein Tristan auf Stufe 5 hat 8.
Ich hatte am Anfang auch nicht so viel, deswegen habe ich 3-mal zusätzlich fokussieren genommen.
Das gibt insgesamt noch mal 6 Stück.
Dann habe ich einen Ring, der 2, 8.
Und dann pro Level, also sag mal so 30 oder so, da ist es mir irgendwie noch gefallen.
53? Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht, oder?
Ach ja, und ich habe noch Weisheitsbonus.
Der macht natürlich auch ein bisschen, aber hä?
Ich weiß auch, keine Ahnung, OP Tristan.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der so viel hat.
Sollen wir lagern mal eine Runde?
Mal gucken, wie viel er dann hat, ob sie das wieder gesettet hat.
Wie viel Uhr haben wir jetzt? 18 Uhr.
Also ich bin jetzt 4 Stunden on.
Ich glaube, ich werde da im nächsten aufgehen, weil ich habe übelst Hunger.
Es sei denn, wir müssen wieder ASMR-Eating-Stream machen.
Hallo Comstar.
Ok, alles erfolgreich, next.
58? Ich hatte nicht mal Level-Up dazwischen.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist ein Bug.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Bug, 58.
Aber mal ein Bug zu meinen Gunsten, ne?
Wir sind auch immer noch auf schwer.
Also keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich meine, 58 mal heilen bedeutet ja am Endeffekt, ich muss eigentlich kaum noch rasten irgendwo, ja?
Vlog im Schnee.
Oh ja, das ist ja schon ewig hier.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit den...
Oh mein Mammut.
Mein Mammut hat so viele Minus-Sachen.
Also ich kann mir ganz gut merken, wann das Vlog im Schnee war.
Es müsste irgendwie so 2030 gewesen sein, weil das habe ich im Garten gemacht.
Hier im Haus, wo wir noch nicht hier gewohnt haben.
Ein Streamer hatte ein Bug, Lizzie36Charisma, WTF.
Wir können ja mal gucken, mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich den Ring ausziehe.
Sollte ich jetzt nicht eigentlich weniger haben, wenn ich den Ring ausziehe?
Okay, wir lagern noch mal, mal gucken, wie es nächsten Tag aussieht.
Max Grill, ne?
Er ist immer sehr diplomatisch.
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie viel wir haben.
56!
Okay, also der Ring macht tatsächlich, was er soll.
Unbestreitbar macht der Ring, was er soll.
Er channelt zweimal mehr.
Ey, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Das müssen wir mal googeln danach.
Das ist ein Bug.
Aha.
Ne?
Wie viele Channels kriegt man eigentlich laut Pathfinder?
Ja, da sieht man es doch, Channel.
Geh weg.
Also.
Ich bin Level 8.
Sagen wir mal, ich wäre Level 9. Das ist jetzt einfacher zu rechnen.
Channel Energy, ist das pro Tag oder was? 5D6?
Das sind ja maximal 30.
Ich könnte maximal 30 kriegen, maximal. Und ich habe 58.
Also 30 hatte ich ja vorher, ne?
Ich glaube, das ist verbackt. An das kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Tja.
Gut, da muss ich wohl mit leben, dass mein Clary jetzt massiv OP ist.
Du hattest 38. Ja, das passt mit 38. 38 passt.
Guck mal. Mal angenommen, ich hätte hier 30. Ich habe einen Ring, der 2 gibt und 3 Talente, die jeweils 2 geben.
38 wäre okay. Aber wtf, 56?
Das ist irgendein merkwürdiger Bug.
Ich starte mal neu, vielleicht bringt das was.
Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr bug hüsen, weil ich mein, man muss schon sagen, 58 mal AE Heal ist schon massiv OP.
Ich habe so viel wie mit Stufe 19.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Also das ist wirklich übelst OP, weil man sich überlegt, das Ding, ich habe ja auch noch viel Cluster Attribut.
Also sprich, ich heile ja auch irgendwie 15 oder so pro Heal.
Ja, Steam, wie sieht es aus?
Steam, please.
Okay, selbst der mächtige Gabenblick hat nichts gebracht.
Okay, einfach so.
Es ist jetzt schon irgendwie unfair.
Ich mache dann quasi 58 AE Heals.
Ich kann quasi meine Gruppe irgendwie 7 mal oder so komplett voll heilen, die ganze Gruppe, bevor ich rasten muss.
Das ist halt schon ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, ich finde die Hexenmeister-Spells schon ziemlich OP.
Ich meine, das sind halt die ganz normalen Arcane-Spellgeschichten, die es halt so gibt in dem Game.
Aber wenn ich mir überlege, dass ich teilweise irgendwie 7 mal oder so Haste casten kann, das ist auch was mit der besten Spell,
als wenn man viele Mele-Damage-Typen hat, plus Pets. Also Haste ist massiv OP in der Party-Zusammensetzung.
Ich meine, ich habe zwei Mele-Typen, zwei Pets und die mit Haste, die gehen ab.
Wieso hast du etwa 30 Videos gelöscht vor deinem 100-Video-Special, das sind nur 70.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendeine YouTube-Geschichte.
Ich habe letztens gesehen, muss ich euch gerade mal zeigen.
Welches Video war das?
Das könnte sogar das gewesen sein.
Nee, das ist das nicht. Welches Video war das? Das hat YouTube komplett verbackt.
Ah ja, Noobs. Wo sind die Noobs hin?
Wie hieß denn das Video? Irgendwie sowas. Wo sind alle Noobs?
Meine Güte. Wo sind die Noobs hin? Das Video ist angeblich 7 Minuten 40.
Jetzt ist es wieder 7 Minuten 40. Gestern war das Video nur noch 1,50.
Ich vermute langsam Verschwörungen auf YouTube.
Es hat auch gestern ein Kommentar gepostet. Warum ist dieses Video nur noch 1,50 Minuten lang?
Das ist weg.
Ach nee, das war ein anderes Video. Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Das war mal ein Windows 10 Video. Das war das.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Das Video sollte eigentlich 9 Minuten 5 sein.
Bei 1,50 hat YouTube kaputt gemacht. Also quasi ein Video, das 6 Jahre alt ist.
Und mich würde nicht wundern, wenn YouTube auch irgendwelche Videos entfernt hätte.
Einfach mal so, weil es verbugt ist. YouTube ist eh der größte Bugscheißhaufen überhaupt.
Der unsicherste. Mit unsicher meine ich nicht, dass es securitymäßig ist.
Sondern für seine Zuschauer und Content-Creator.
Du hast keine Ahnung, auf welchen Grund YouTube irgendwas entscheidet.
Naja.
Aber ein Video, das 6 Jahre alt ist, zu kürzen auf 1,50, da ist wahrscheinlich beim encoden was schief gegangen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, die wollten wahrscheinlich alte Videos nach WebM und VP9 oder wie das Zeug heißt, encoden.
Dabei ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen.
So Tristan, 56.
Ich kann mich nicht dagegen wehren. Mein Clary ist verbugt und hat Channels wie ein Level 19 Clary.
Okay, alles klar Tristan, gut ist.
Hallo Captain Paul, das war aber komisch oder? Zumal mein Clary jetzt massiv OP ist.
Und hätte ich das gewusst, dann hätte ich auch nicht dreimal Channel-Talente verschwendet, sondern hätte einfach irgendwas anderes gespeckt.
Keine Ahnung, was weiß ich.
Also wir wissen, dass es hier mit der Main-Quest nicht weiter geht.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt in die Hauptstadt zurück und hoffen, dass wir dort irgendwie eine Main-Quest wieder kriegen.
Oder mein verbugter Clary hat meine Main-Quest verbugt.
Machst du auch mal wieder was auf YouTube? Ja, mach ich.
Sobald es wieder Games gibt, die ich geil finde, die sich auch für YouTube eignen.
Auf der Straße ist jemand, mach dich bereit.
Ich bin immer bereit. So als Fahrtfinder ist man das.
Mal gucken, was jetzt hier kommt.
Moment, die hauen ab von mir. So geht es ja nicht. Lindsay, Person halten.
Trolle, da Fuck. So, wenigstens eingeschreckt.
Ja, die Trolle haben Schiss von mir, seit ich den Anführer gekillt habe.
Beschweren sich alle bei diesen Spielungen in Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Komplett der Witz.
Man sieht mal, wie die Gegner hier weggeklatscht werden.
Und das ist schon auch schwieriger als normal.
Ist trotzdem easy mode.
Ja, wir können gleich resten. Ach was, Yolo, wir resten nicht.
Resten. Resten ist komplett, oh Fuck.
Jetzt wird komplett ausgepowert der Truppe. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die noch laufen können.
Weil ab einem gewissen Ermüdungsgrad, ab einem gewissen Ermüdungsgrad können die nicht mehr laufen.
Aber da sieht man wieder, wie viele Noobs auf Steam Bewertungen schreiben.
Und auf Amazon ist es genauso.
Bei Amazon hat dem Spiel einer eins von fünf gegeben, weil es am Anfang ein Zeitlimit gibt.
Aber man muss sagen, das Zeitlimit, ähm, das ist eigentlich nur dafür gedacht,
dass du irgendwie bei der Sache bleibst, ist nicht wirklich zeitkritisch.
Also es gibt am Anfang in dem Game ein Zeitlimit von 90 Tagen, wo man seine Mainquests erledigen muss.
Also am Anfang vom Spiel ist das Gebiet, das man rein kann, das ist ungefähr so hier, das hier.
Also man kann da nicht allzu weit am Anfang.
Und dafür hat man 90 Tage Zeit, die Mainquests zu erledigen.
Und in der Regel, also wenn man, ich hab mir jedes einzelne Gebiet angeguckt, alle Quests gemacht,
in diesem Zeitlimit und ich hab noch 35 Tage übrig von 90.
Und ich hab alles gemacht, du kannst gar nicht mehr machen.
Und ich hab's auch noch auf schwer gespielt, also auf, äh, fordern.
Das ist kein wirkliches Zeitlimit, das ist einfach nur, dass man jetzt halt nicht komplett unnötige Dinge macht,
weil sie wollen ja später, wenn sich die Karte öffnet, dass du dann quasi dort erst so richtig das Gefühl hast,
jetzt in die Spielwelt rauszugehen.
Dass du am Anfang halt noch so denkst, so, ja ich muss mich jetzt auf meine Quests konzentrieren.
Und deswegen hat wirklich ein Spiel eins von fünf gegeben.
Tristan hat die Flussjungfrau geschreckt.
Die Straße ist fertig.
Der baut immer noch rum.
Thronsaal.
Gerüchte zufolge ist in der Region ein unbekannter, selbstgeschulter Meister.
Aha.
Jaja, mehr Händler sind immer gut.
Das sollte am besten Tristan machen, der kann Leute gut überzeugen.
Ähm.
Sonst noch irgendwas, was ich.
Zehn Prozent reduzierte, oh nee.
Tristan, geh weg.
Abbrechen.
Das muss Tristan machen.
Tristan muss Gebäude um zehn Prozent reduzieren lassen, das ist viel wichtiger.
So.
Er kann das machen und den Handwerker kann auch Valery überreden.
Wunderbar.
So, easy.
So regiert man ein Königreich, ganz einfach.
Einfach paar Karten anklicken, Leute zuweisen und easy money.
Thronsaal, woanders können wir nicht hin.
Ja, Rise ist echt so.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die Leute haben verlernt Spiele zu spielen, wo man mal ein bisschen sich Gedanken machen muss.
Ich finde es nice, dass man Mammut den Kopf durchs Banner stecken hat.
Er hat meinen Untertanen Angst gemacht, das ist ja unerhört.
Die Götter verschmäht, oh nein, das geht ja gar nicht.
Ihr müsst euch um den Wahnsinnigen kümmern.
Wir sind uns schon einmal begegnet vor Olex Handelsbocken.
Sind wir das?
Weiß ich nicht, ja.
Es geht an euch, Schicksal ist hier.
Reden wir über die Prophezei.
Woher wisst ihr das?
Erzählt mir von dieser Gattin.
Diplomatie.
Ich habe gute Chancen das zu packen.
Erfolgreich.
Nice.
So wird regiert, so geht das.
Gehen wir pennen jetzt eine Runde und dann hoffe ich, dass ich irgendwann meine Main-Quest weiter machen kann.
Hat mein Mammut immer noch Minus-Stats?
Ich kann meinen Mammut nicht mehr auswählen.
Bei Hund wurde ein Konstitutionsschaden erneuert.
Okay, da pennen wir nochmal eine Runde und gucken ob wieder was erneuert wird.
Vielleicht ist das Mammut jetzt ja auch geheilt.
Das ist ein Minecraft-Turnier, da habe ich nichts mit am Hut.
Ich war ja nie der große Minecraft-Spieler.
Auch wenn ich mal einen Minecraft selber hatte.
Okay, das ist toll, weil ich habe zwei beschworene Tiere am Start.
Mein Mammut hat 50 Stärke.
Leider hat mein Mammut Minus-Stats und ich weiß nicht genau warum.
Vielleicht müsste ich da auch mal eine Genesungsschriftrolle draufhauen oder so.
Hatte ich hier nicht eine? Ich hatte doch eine Genesungsschriftrolle.
Sortiert nach Datum.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich die verwenden kann.
Natürlich nicht.
Keine Genesungsschriftrolle.
Mal kurz hier gucken, ob was passiert ist.
Minecraft hat immer noch mehr Spieler als Fortnite.
Wo kommt diese Statistik her?
Man kann es davon abgesehen, dass es ja auch immer ein bisschen ein weiter geholtes Vergleich ist.
In einem Spiel, wo quasi jeder Surfer installieren kann.
So viel Community drumherum ist schon über Jahre.
Ich bin echt interessiert, wie die Statistik ist an Fortnite verkauft.
Es gibt eh viele Spieler, die noch viel mehr gespielt haben, als man denkt.
Zum Beispiel Warcraft 3 ist im chinesischen und russischen Raum übelst beliebt.
Immer noch. 15 Jahre nachdem es rausgekommen ist.
Und auch wieder im westlichen Raum wird das tatsächlich mehr.
Was muss ich mal vorstellen? Blizzard macht anscheinend keine neuen gescheiten Games mehr.
Weil die Leute schon wieder Warcraft 3 auspacken müssen.
Es gibt sogar Patches für Warcraft 3. Balance Patches bei einem 50 Jahre alten Spiel.
Da kann man Blizzard wirklich nichts vorwerfen, das nicht zu supporten.
Ich muss das andere Gebiet noch erweitern, aber irgendwie verdiene ich zu wenig Kohle.
Keine Ahnung.
Es würde mich interessieren, was das für eine Statistik ist, wo die herkommt.
Und wie man das ermittelt hat, dass Minecraft mehr Spieler hat.
So, Quests. Ich habe keine Quests mehr.
Ah, Schluck auf in 2K18.
Ja, ich weiß. Warcraft 3 kriegt Patches.
Okay, was gibt es Neues?
Sag mir, wo ich meine Quests kriege.
Ihr habt gewiss viele Fähre. Ihr seid eine wirklich schöne Frau.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken, wie die das ermittelt haben, dass Minecraft mehr aktive Spieler hat.
Ich kann mir das schon vorstellen.
Also, Minecraft hat noch immer mehr aktive Spieler als Fortnite.
Microsoft hat neue Zahlen zu Minecraft veröffentlicht.
Laut diesem Spiel liegt das Spiel um 91 Millionen aktive Spieler.
Ja, Moment, wie misst das Microsoft denn?
Das ist bestimmt wie in WoW, wo die 12 Millionen aktive Spieler hatten.
Dabei hatten sie 12 Millionen Abos.
Ja, das kann ich mir aber gut vorstellen.
Ich meine, Minecraft hat ja da auch gute Voraussetzungen für.
Das hat jahrelang aufgebaute Community, jahrelang aufgebaute Server, Server zum selbst installieren.
Mods in Massen, leider in Java.
Aber halt, dann doch.
Alter, ich wollte es nicht auf...
Ich wollte es auf meinen Mammut anwenden.
Alter, jetzt muss ich noch eine neue Schriftrolle kaufen.
Okay, ja, ich habe echt meine Probleme, wo meine Mainquest ist.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach...
Ich gehe jetzt in Thronraum und mache einfach noch ein paar sinnlose Verwaltungsquests.
Und dann kriege ich bestimmt meine neue Mainquest.
Was haben alle gegen Java?
Schwierig zu sagen.
Ja, nichts Wirksames.
Nee, also Java an sich, eigentlich ist Java nicht schlecht.
Java hat so ein paar merkwürdige Dinge.
Außerdem ist es mittlerweile Oracle und Oracle ist halt Oracle.
Oracle will eigentlich kaum einer, der nicht unbedingt muss was zu tun haben.
Also man kann Sachen durchaus in Java machen, das ist...
Ja, aber wenn ich nicht unbedingt muss, würde ich es nicht machen.
Okay, machen wir mal sinnlose Quests.
Also Regionen, Ereignisse.
Ach, Moment, ich weiß, welche Quest noch aussteht.
Die Quest in 120 Tagen, die mit dem Hügel steht ja noch aus.
Unterstützt das Vorhaben.
Okay, was kann man noch alles unterstützen?
Okay, ich muss erstmal warten, bis die Projekte abgeschlossen sind.
14 Tage 36.
Was genau macht eigentlich mein Camera gerade?
Wo ist der dran?
Ein echtes Meisterwerk macht der.
Das da, in drei Tagen, okay.
Eins, zwei, drei, nice.
Erfolg, easy.
Ja, das können wir gleich machen.
Jetzt helfen wir erstmal...
Jetzt verbessern wir erstmal die Wirtschaft.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nämlich, was mit der Main-Quest weitergeht.
Wenn ich diese komische Hügel-Quest fertig habe, wenn ich die Hügel-Quest fertig habe,
ich habe aber nur eine Hügel-Quest, wenn ich die gemacht habe, dann ist gut.
Und die ist aus den 100 Tagen fertig, deswegen klicken wir jetzt mal sinnlose 14 Tage Projekte durch.
Was?
Ach, Valerie.
Haha, wir können ja neu laden. Also die Handelsstraße sollte schon gebaut werden.
Zum Glück wird das Schalter nicht am Anfang, sondern am Ende gewürfelt.
Siehste, damn.
Cheat, hack.
Okay, Ereignisse.
Kamerabedarf von Aufmerksamkeit, im Schloss wartet ein Besucher.
Jedes hilft ein bisschen, das darfst du machen.
Ergebnis starten.
Projekte.
Loyalität.
Was? Warum habe ich jetzt Minus gekriegt?
Weil ich den Typ nicht empfangen habe, oder was?
Alter, das muss einem das Game doch auch mal sagen, dass das nicht wartet.
Fuck, ey.
Game Lull.
Warum, das hat das...
Das wusste ich überhaupt nicht, dass man den Typen auch empfangen muss,
dass sie nicht einfach warten, bis man Zeit für sich hat.
Man muss immer dann hier.
Ich bin ein krasser Baron.
Ich bin beschäftigt.
Ich kann jetzt nicht in Thronsaal.
Gut, nice.
Gut, speichern, dann gehen wir wieder in Thronsaal und dann geht es hoffentlich weiter.
Ein neuer Besucher im Schloss, da kann man laufen.
Okay, kann man sonst noch irgendwas bauen?
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal in Thronsaal und lassen uns die Ohren abkauen.
Wann kommt mal wieder ein neues Video von dir, sobald es Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Und die sich für YouTube eignen.
Oder ich Kohle brauche.
Null Sellout.
Mammut ist am Start.
Ein unterretzter Mann um die 30 kommt auf dich zu.
Die Kriminalität nimmt zu.
Hallo, ich habe Militär plus 55 oder so.
Ich bitte euch, finde diese Schurken und holt mir meinen Schatz zurück.
Ich bezahle euch eine hübsche Summe.
Wenn ihr...
Stimmt, ich war da.
Warum ist das neutral gut, wenn ich sage, der Fluch existiert.
Obwohl wir vorher in der Quest herausgefunden haben, dass es keinen Fluch gibt.
Die Dialogoptionen sind teilweise schon ganz schön beknackt.
Aber gut, wenn sich die Einheimischen davon vorthalten sollen, ist Galio schlecht.
Was arbeitest du, wenn ich fragen darf?
Ich kümmere mich um unsere Software, unsere Source Code Verwaltung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt erklären soll, wenn man nicht...
Wie erklärt man das am besten?
Stell dir vor, jemand will eine neue Software Version rausbringen.
Also Version 2 oder sowas.
Du musst dir irgendwie gucken, wie kriegst du alle Features rein.
Wie kommen sich die Entwickler untereinander nicht ins Gehege.
Was passiert, wenn der eine was macht, was dem anderen was kaputt macht.
Das pflegt man alles in einem Source Code Verwaltungssystem.
Irgendeiner muss sich darum kümmern, dass sich nichts ins Gehege kommt.
Gucken, dass die neue Version rechtzeitig fertig wird.
Und dass man das alles rechtzeitig ausgerollt kriegt und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das mache ich.
Ich hoffe, das konnte man jetzt verstehen.
Falls nicht, kann ich dir das genauer erklären.
Also gelernt habe ich mal Fachinformatiker System Integration vor einigen Jahrzehnten.
Also Jahrzehnte ist es schon her, aber Jahrzehnte noch nicht.
Und danach habe ich ziemlich viel mit Linux an sich.
Netzwerk, Hochverfügbarkeit, Rechenzentrum, Betrieb und solche Dinge gemacht.
Ja.
Wir müssen über Steuern reden.
Ich würde an eurer Stelle die Steuermoderat erhöhen.
Moment, kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich die Steuern nicht erhöhen will?
Ich bin da Baron.
Wenn ich sage, ich will meine Steuern nicht erhöhen, dann will ich meine Steuern nicht erhöhen.
Ah, mach einfach mal.
So, habe ich.
Wie lange dauert denn jetzt der Quest?
52 Tage, okay, wir müssen noch ein 14 Tage Projekt machen, dann können wir die Quest beenden.
Und dann geht es hoffentlich mit der Main Quest weiter.
Spielwerte, Beziehung, Beziehung aber nicht so geil.
Realität ist schon auf Stufe 2.
Okay, das soll ich starten.
Ereignisse.
275 habe ich nicht.
400 habe ich auch nicht.
Der kann ich.
Der kann.
Der ist beschäftigt, okay.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir denn jetzt noch?
Das ist also das am Stück die Verwaltung ist wirklich nur ein Sleeper pur.
So, wie lange dauert es jetzt noch bis der?
Ja, ich würde den Rat gerne erweisen, aber ich finde da keine Leute, die da mitmachen wollen.
So, alter Flugteil 2, 38 Tage, okay.
Noch ein 14 Tage Projekt.
Man kann ab 30 Tagen, kann man hin zum Berg und Monster bashen.
Und dann gucken wir, ob die Main Quest weitergeht.
Wähle einen Berater für diese Stellung.
Jeder ist gerade beschäftigt mit magischer Wind.
Magischer Wind dauert, ach du scheiße, 21 Tage mit dir.
25 Tage.
Okay, da klicken wir jetzt einfach achtmal.
Eins.
Vier.
Fünf.
Ereignisse.
Der hohe Priester sucht meinen Rat.
Tristan, du kannst das machen.
Du kannst das auch machen.
Und dann besuche ich jetzt noch den Thronsaal.
Dann haben wir es glaube ich.
Hyper Residenz Sleeper ist es, da reicht der normale schon nicht mehr.
Alle Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich muss demnächst mal Schluss machen oder ich futter jetzt was hier dabei.
Ich bringe schlechte Nachrichten.
Es ist mir vollkommen wurscht ehrlich gesagt.
Bin ich für einen Baron?
Drei Tage noch.
So, der hohe Priester.
Ich hab glaub ich nichts mehr übrig.
Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
Vier.
Jetzt kann ich die Quest machen.
Wir entholen nicht die Stange.
Gäste aus dem Nachbarland.
Ja, machen wir alles.
Moin CheesyBron.
Hä, was?
Was genau wollen Sie?
Er will jetzt eins von mir.
Ja, lade die Gäste ein, alles gut.
Okay, ich glaube es geht weiter mit der Quest.
Nice.
Quest Tours.
Oder wird das erst 14 Tage davor aktiv.
Moin, Alpha Dio.
Ja, das ist auch die neue Main Quest.
Na Gott sei Dank, wir haben es geschafft.
Main Quest Tours.
Gibt es heute Abend, weiß das jemand, gibt es heute Abend irgendwelche E-Sport Veranstaltungen oder sonstige Sachen,
die man gucken kann auf Twitch?
Weil ich sag mal so allzu allwählig wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, fast 5 Stunden oder so am Start, wie lange sind wir am Start?
4.40, ja das ist schon ein bisschen.
Ich geh jetzt zur Jagdhütte und dann jagen wir zünftig mit unseren Nachbarn.
Und wahrscheinlich müssen wir dabei 500 Monster bashen.
Morgen früh um 6 Uhr gibt es Loll Worlds.
Ich gucke ja kein Loll, das ist das Problem.
Ich bin mit Mobas zum Gucken auch nie warm geworden, also zum Selbstspielen gar nicht.
Zum Gucken auch nicht, wohingegen ich Hearthstone gucke, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Hearthstone gucke, Starcraft gucke, also auch Sachen, die ich nicht spiele.
Ich hab mir letztens sogar ein Puppgeturnier angeguckt.
Leute habt ihr schonmal einen Puppgeturnier geguckt?
Ein Puppgeturnier?
Also jetzt nicht wo Streamer spielen, sondern wo wirklich die Pros spielen.
Das ist ultra langweilig, das ist ultra langweilig.
Ich weiß, dass ich den Typ im Thronraum empfangen hab.
Ich hab geguckt, irgendein koreanisches Turnierpupke.
Das hab ich rausgekriegt, weil ich hab ja noch von Overwatch hier OGN damals,
das sind die, die Apex und so gemacht haben, hatte ich ja noch abonniert.
Irgendwie stand dann auf einmal da, ist jetzt online und es läuft ein Puppgeturnier.
Hab ich angemacht, das war dann irgendwie ein 4 vs 4 vs 4 vs 4 vs 4.
Ihr verstehts, das war so langweilig.
Die haben alle im Busch gelegen, die haben die komplette Runde gefühlt im Busch gelegen.
Oder hinterm Felsen gesessen oder irgendwie in der Rinne gelegen.
Das war grausam, das hat wirklich wehgetan beim Zugucken.
Also das hat geschmerzt beim Zugucken.
Dies ist keine gewöhnliche Jagd, unsere Beute sind keine Hasen oder Dinge,
sondern Eulenbeeren Hydrin, sind Hydrin die Mehrzahl von Hydra.
Ich dachte, man darf Hydras sagen, genauso wie man Pizzas sagen darf.
Hydrin, ist das, muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Hydrin, das hört sich eher so nach Hydrant oder so an.
Hydrin.
Mehrzahl Hydra.
Ja.
Die Hydra, der Hydra, der Hydra, die Hydra.
Die Hydrin.
Der Hydrin, den Hydrin, die Hydrin.
Ok, die haben Recht.
Es heißt tatsächlich Hydrin.
Haben wir da was gelernt?
Rechtschreiben in 2K18, sag ich dazu nur.
Das ist aber Hyperlul.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
So, weiter, fortfahren.
Was sollen wir eigentlich genau machen?
3 Schrägde.
Ok, wir müssen Gegner bashen und Trophäen zurückbringen und dann sind wir geil.
Gäste untersuchen, Gäste untersuchen.
Aha, der Star Bart sozusagen.
Was ist in der Truhe?
Die Jagd beginnt, ich bin bereit.
Klar.
Google Rechtschreibprüfung.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht von Google gewesen.
Das ist von Vicky Chonary.
Dann schauen wir gleich viel geiler.
Ok, hat man eine?
Ok, das verstehe ich bei dem Game nicht.
Man hat bei Quests, wo es nicht wirklich notwendig ist, teilweise eine Zeitlimit.
Und bei einer Quest, die quasi im Questtext schon sagt, es gibt eine Zeitlimit, hat man kein Zeitlimit.
Warum?
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Erstmal schön das Gasthaus ausplünden.
Ach, Lindsay, komm on.
Wir knacken jetzt einfach die Kiste und machen bei dieser komischen...
Ach, Lindsay, komm.
Was würfelst du denn?
Schwierigkeit 24.
Du hast bloß 14.
Lindsay, bloß 14.
Du kannst das eigentlich, du musst einfach nur 6 oder mehr werfen, dass die Truhe geknackt wird.
Da ist ja nicht mal was drinnen.
Das ist mein Berater, oder?
Was macht der da?
Es wird immer interessanter.
Blablabla, wie läuft die Jagd?
Ich sollte gehen.
So, dann gehen wir mal auf die Jagd und bashen ein paar Monster.
Oder auch nicht, ich hab immer noch wahnsinnig Hunger.
Jagdrevierer.
Mindestens zwei der drei magischen Bestientöten.
Okay, solange man kein Zeitlimit da hat und angezeigt wird, muss man sich nicht beeilen.
Aber wir safen mal.
Und nachdem wir ja einen tollen Hexenmeister dabei haben, machen wir jetzt einfach mal Speed an.
Und düsen los.
Das hält leider nicht so lange.
Looten können wir nachher.
Moment, dafür muss Zeit sein.
Moment, die Map ist ganz schön groß, ne?
Wie läuft die Jagd?
Ja, warum soll ich die jetzt killen, WTF?
Das ist natürlich für die Beziehung zum Nachbarland bestimmt besonders gut, wenn ich ihre Gesandten einfach mal kille.
Die können nix, das sind die Billigwölfe.
Die Level 3 Wölfe sind das, die können gar nix.
Ach ne, die sind gebufft, das ist die gebuffte Version von den Wölfen.
Hier gehts nicht weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier oben?
Essbares Moos, wieder was für das Mammut.
Der Miri kriegt so viel Schaden.
Ohne Selfheal ist er auch grottenschlecht.
Verschlossen.
Das können allerdings die Monster.
Ungemerkt.
Das Game, wo es alle heulen, was der Schwierigkeit gerade so hoch ist.
Verschlossen?
Ja, Lindsay, mach.
Lindsay, mach auf.
Und die hat schon irgendwie sonst was geskillt zum Schlösserknacken.
Wir haben uns um eins gefällt.
Oh Mann, das ist halt ein fragwürdiges Design, das ist neu laden.
Schwere Hammer, der Kniespalter ist am Start.
Schwere Verderben, Streithammer, Riesen plus 2.
Das ist ja fast ein Diablo 2 Item Name.
So könnte den Gegner in Diablo 2 heißen.
In Diablo 2 hatten die Gegner ganz abgedrehte Namen.
Falls das überhaupt noch irgendjemand kennt.
Dann haben wir wirklich jenseits von guten und bösen Diablo 2 Gegnern Namen.
Kann man hier hoch vielleicht?
Oh tatsächlich, nice.
Da lang.
Aber hier kann man wirklich hoch, das ist cool.
Max, beeil dich.
Eine Falle.
Nicht auslösen, wenn es geht.
Der Boden ist übersetzt, das heißt hier gibt es jetzt Bosskampf.
Oder mal gucken wie stark das Ding ist.
Da ist er.
Moment, so Viecher haben wir doch unterwegs schon massig gekillt.
Oh, Amiri hat einfach Gift.
Da hätte ich vielleicht doch nicht so noobmäßig rangehen sollen.
Gift verzögern.
Was habt ihr nur?
Was?
Wir müssen Amiri mal heilen.
Die hat Konstitution minus 2.
Gut, danach müssen wir mal rasten, das passt schon.
Jetzt habe ich nur noch 12 Channels.
Was zum Teufel ist mit dem Game nicht richtig?
What the fuck?
Was ist mit dem Game kaputt, Alter?
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Jetzt habe ich nur 12, 48, 58, jetzt habe ich 12, das ist komplett random irgendwie.
Das ist ziemlich verbackt an der Stelle.
Das ist nicht weit.
Hab ich hier alles jetzt abgesahnt?
Nee, da ist noch Pilsen, Pilzsourz.
Okay Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich war 5 Stunden oder so am Start.
Mir reicht es heute.
Gucken, ob wir uns morgen wieder sehen.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob wir morgen nicht mal wieder ein Programmier-Stream machen.
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Wir müssen ja hier das Meme-Tool mal endlich eine Datenbank einbauen,
dass wir auch Settings speichern können und neue Sachen hinzufügen können und sowas.
Vielleicht machen wir das morgen.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich werde jetzt erst mal safen und ausmachen und was fottern.
Leute, wir sehen uns morgen.
Macht es gut.
Bis dann.
See you.
Bye.